All right. What's up, y'all? As always,
welcome to another live stream. Uh,
tonight we're going to be breaking the
ice on the topic of the Sabbath. If
there's one thing that most people
typically know about 7th day Adventism,
it is their beating of the 7th day
Sabbath drum. For those that maybe don't
know, the narrative that they put out is
basically this, that the 7th day Sabbath
was changed by the Roman Catholic papacy
as a sign of usurping authority that
only God has. And this change to Sunday
is supposedly the papal Sabbath and will
eventually be the mark of the beast. Uh
once a national turned international
Sunday law is passed, forcing the world
to treat Sunday as the Sabbath. It is at
that point that Seventh Day Adventists
will have to take a stand for the
seventh day Sabbath and be persecuted
for doing so. in their adherence to the
seventh day Sabbath, they will then be
given the seal of God. So whether you
are an Adventist or not, hopefully
tonight's stream will be beneficial as
this is a topic many people have
uncertainties about. Um there are
various ideas out there regarding the
Sabbath. And regardless of where you are
on the spectrum, I hope you will give my
guest tonight a fair shake as he loves
the word of God and he is going to help
us see the bigger picture around the
Sabbath as a whole. uh why Christians
worship on the day that they do and kind
of help us work through some of these
conspiracies that the Adventist church
has hoisted upon people ultimately
filling them with fear and paranoia. So
with that said, Dr. Brandt Bosserman got
his PhD from Bangor University, an MAT
from Fuller Theological Seminary, and a
BA from Northwest University. Upon
completing his PhD in philosophy of
religion in 2012, his thesis was
published under the title, get this
folks, the trinity and the vindication
of Christian paradox in interpretation
and refinement of the theological
apologetic of Cornelius Vanill. Say that
three times fast. The same year he was
ordained in the PCA, the denomination
that I'm affiliated with, and called to
uh and was called to plant Trinitas
Presbyterian Church in Mil Creek,
Washington. He enjoys bringing to bear
trinitarian theology, reformed doctrine,
and presuppositional apologetics in his
role as a preacher, youth minister, and
as an adjunct professor. He has an
exogetical article that's actually
coming out on the Sabbath in the
Westminster Journal in the fall, after
which we're hoping to have him back on
here to go a little bit deeper into this
topic and the biblical support for the
Christian practice of worshiping on
Sunday. So, tonight will be just a
little bit of a primer, if you will.
But after all that, Dr. Bosserman, thank
you, sir, for being here.
Thanks for having me. Good to uh finally
make your uh semiface to face
acquaintance smiles over uh over the
internet, but glad to be on and glad to
participate. Yeah, for sure. I uh I saw
you on Jeremiah Norier. I'll say it like
a very Americanized person. Um and I
heard you mention that you're writing
this article and I said, you know, I got
to get this guy on here. I knew about
your stuff prior to um that regarding
the Trinity, especially Van Hill. I
thought about you the other day. I got
this as well. We were talking earlier on
um books and I was in the Westminster
bookstore and I saw that that was also
on sale which is for those that don't
know it was a Christian theory of
knowledge by Cornelius Vanill. They
reprinted
and so I thought of you when I was
getting that and so I'm saying all that
to say I'm very grateful that you're
here. I think that this would be very
beneficial. So, uh, I know I just gave a
little bit of a rundown there, but tell
us a little bit about yourself, who you
are, um, and why tonight's topic on this
one in particular is of interest to you.
Yeah. Well, I'll jump straight in. Um,
you know, my connection in the realm of
theology to Sabbath discussion and
especially the concept of seventh day
Sabbathkeeping doesn't come from the
Seventh Day Adventist uh tradition
directly, but from kind of an offshoot,
a group called the Worldwide Church of
God. Um, in the 1930s, a fellow started
a radio program named Herbert W.
Armstrong. And, um, at that time, he was
affiliated with Adventism. Um, I believe
he was a member of a 7th Day Adventist
church in in Oregon somewhere. But
eventually that program developed into
the the biggest uh religious broadcast
in the country, eventually became called
the World Tomorrow. And my grandfather,
though he was um raised Roman Catholic,
maybe a bit nominally, um he began
listening to Herbert W. Armstrong's uh
radio show and uh converted to the
worldwide church of God. Um you know the
worldwide church of God held on to the
whole belief that the seventh day is the
appropriate day of worship. Um and also
had the same sorts of um views that
failure to worship on the seventh day um
was one of the shest outward marks that
one doesn't really uh have a genuine
faith in the God of the Bible. Now, of
course, Worldwide Church of God differs
from 7th Day Adventist seriously in its
theology and that it is uh totally
totally heretical um denying the
doctrine of the Trinity, the personality
of the Holy Spirit, um the full deity of
Christ. Um and and so in that respect,
it differs from Adventism or 7th day
Adventism, but um on the whole question
of the se seventh day Sabbath, um
they're agreed. And so my dad was was
raised in that particular sect until uh
young adulthood and then he came out of
it and um became became an evangelical
Christian. But debates about uh the
seventh day, the fourth commandment, um
the appropriate time of worship were
just live in my house um from as long as
I can remember with my grandpa on one
side of the debate, my dad's twin
brother became a uh minister in the
worldwide church of God, and then my dad
and my big brother and I on the other.
So, it's something we're really familiar
with. And I guess the last thing I'd say
is, you know, personally passed through
the permutations of, you know, my dad
having once been seventh day sabotarian
to being more broadly evangelical where
maybe the Lord hasn't um, you know,
called us uh by command necessarily to
worship on any specific day or even
abdominally. Um, that's it's one day and
seven um to coming to a a reformed
conviction in adulthood about the first
day. um being the time in which we're to
um fulfill the fourth commandment um or
at least obey the fourth commandment
would be a better way to put it.
Yeah. Um and I would say too so when I
came out of Adventism that was obviously
one of like the big things and I wasn't
reformed at the time. Um I actually
would have been um I didn't know the
technical terminology at the time. Um
but I would have been like with
hindsight you're kind of like hyper
anti-reformed guy. um kind of hearing
these bad arguments from people that
weren't reformed. Um and so I kind of
had some of these same understandings as
well of the Sabbath and I was kind of
using these same sorts of arguments um
that I didn't think were actually over
time as strong as say the reformed
position. So I'll be excited to get into
some of that tonight. So um what role
does the Sabbath play in the biblical
narrative about redemption and creation?
Because I don't think most people um
even 7th day sabotarian groups whether
you're a first day sabotarian, 7th day
sabotarian, non-sabotarian, I don't
think a lot of people have a full orbed
understanding around
how wide of a spectrum the Sabbath
actually encompasses. So um can you
expound upon that a little bit? Yeah.
Yeah. So I mean I think we can expand on
this question a lot. I think this is um
one of the focal points of our
discussion about any you know enduring
application of the fourth commandment
for you've got to understand the
commandment in the first place and uh
what it exists to do before we can
really talk about how we would apply it
faithfully today. So you know I want to
begin with the concept that um holy days
in the Bible um are consistently
uh given to mankind to uh function as um
a means by which we remember and recall
as a form of worship God's greatest
deeds in history in time. This is a
consistent feature of uh biblical holy
days and u you know obviously well
before we reach the New Testament when
you look at the Sabbath command in
Exodus 20 and Deuteronomy 5 really
Exodus 20:8 um it begins with the
command to remember
um this tells you that the Sabbath day
is supposed to function as a witness and
a sign of something that God has done in
the past. And this is going to be true
of all of the holy days that God
institutes in one way or another. Um,
specifically, you know, I'll just point
out that the word uh the Hebrew word
zakar for remember, it's it's the same
word that's prevalent in Genesis 9 uh
verses 8 through1 17 where God gives the
sign of the of the rainbow in the
heavens. And and it's given as a
memorial for remembrance of something
that God did in the past uh both to men
and The text is emphatic to God as well.
Uh it's there uh for us to remember that
God remembers that he has once judged
the world uh in this all-encompassing
way. And um it al also anticipates that
he will judge the world again not by
water but by fire. Um, but the point
though just to begin is part of worship
is remembering God's great deeds. And
that's one of the prime functions of the
fourth commandment in all of its
applications, whether it be to a weekly
Sabbath or to the annual Sabbath that
God instituted in the Old Testament.
Does that make enough sense, Miles?
Yes, sir. Yes. So, well, going from
there, you know, building on that, you
know, I just I really want to, you know,
cinch down on this theme and really try
to expound it for a little bit. Most
will know that in the Old Testament,
there were three mandatory annual holy
days um that one would have to appear at
the u Jerusalem temple, um at the
Passover, um at Pentecost, and at
tabernacles. And I'm just going to drill
down on the theme again that these all
have historical value. The Passover of
course recalls the people of Israel's
redemption from Egypt. And you know it's
expounded in Exodus 12 through13 how
that is to be kept. And um it's also
telling you about the fateful Eve in
which the destroying angel went
throughout the land and um you know
slayed all of the firstborn of the
Egyptians but not the Israelites. that
day was to be kept as a remembrance of
that historical redemptive event for
Israel. Pentecost, it's it's a lesser
known to most that if you're carefully
reading Exodus 19, it's clear that
Pentecost um or 50 days after the
Passover coincides with the giving of
the law on Mount Si. Um so, so there's
that historical reference uh you know
behind that holy day. And then of course
tabernacles is explicitly described as a
holy day um that recalls Israel's
wandering in the wilderness where people
would dwell for eight days in booths uh
near unto Jerusalem. And of course the
theme persists all throughout the Old
Testament in Esther after the people of
Israel rescued from national genocide at
the hands of of Persia. The text is
really clear that
that that God put it on the hearts of
the people to institute a a an annual
holiday of Purim um or lots. Um this
persists out of the Old Testament into
you know the Mcabes you know Hanukkah
obviously being uh a celebration of um
the cleansing of the temple and
deliverance from Antiochus IV and the
Salucan dynasty who had had dominance
over Israel at the time. You know,
frankly, even lesser known days get
commemorized um in keeping with this
principle. Um there's a day called Yom
Nanner
discussed in in the Makabian literature
as well that was uh instituted to u
recall Israel's victory over Nanner um a
you know a powerful warlord who employed
elephants and his armies and things like
that. And so the first thing that we've
got to have in our mind is that one of
the commandments God has given us is a
commandment to set aside God, you know,
time to remember God's mighty deeds. And
once we understand this, this is going
to have some pretty radical
implications, you know, when it comes to
New Testament worship and its
appropriate timing. Um, and before I
jump straight into that, you still
tracking with me, Miles? We good so far?
We're good so far, brother.
Okay. So, the last thing I'm going to
mention though is is something with
respect to the Sabbath. Now, the Sabbath
being a one day in seven holy day, um
clearly it's going to have to
commemorate as it's observed the most
frequently the most mighty and important
deeds of Yahweh um as creator and
redeemer. And so, what do you find? Of
course, but in Exodus 20, uh the
rationale for the Sabbath command is
given and um the function of the day is
given. It says, "Remember the Sabbath to
keep it holy. For in six days the Lord
made the heavens and the earth, the sea,
and all that is in them, and rested on
the seventh day. Therefore, the Lord
blessed the Sabbath day and made it
holy." It was the responsibility of
God's people as an act of worship to
remember God's mighty deed of creation
and his completion of it uh unfolding
into a an eternal rest. You know, God
ever being in that seventh day, not
doing more labors in a work week after
that. But it's important that as
redemptive history unfolds,
so too does the focus of the Sabbath
command. When this law is repeated in
Deuteronomy 5, uh we're told in in verse
12 that we are to observe the Sabbath
day to keep it holy. But when the
rationale is given, the the rationale
given is that you shall remember that
you were a slave in the land of Egypt
and the Lord your God brought you out of
there by a mighty hand and by an
outstretched arm. Therefore, the Lord
commanded you to observe the Sabbath
day. Implicit in this alteration is a
very deep theological insight. As mighty
as the work of creation was,
creation was bringing into being, giving
life in relationship uh to personal
creations who had no deserts because
they didn't exist.
But for God to have grace on a people in
history and to call them his firstborn
son and confer to them relationship and
new life
when they didn't not only uh had no
desserts for it but deserved the very
opposite
is a more wonderful thing than creation
itself.
That's what this development and focus
tells you. Once we understand that the
point of the fourth commandment is to
commemorate by rest from our normal
labors and uh by devotion of ourselves
wholeheartedly to the remembering of the
mightiest deeds of God. Um, it is
entirely natural that the New Testament
people would understand the fourth
commandment has to be kept with
reference not to the creation and not
with reference to the redemption from
Egypt but with reference to Jesus Christ
resurrection from the dead. Um, you you
consider uh you consider this radical
earthshaking event and consider the
commandment first. The fourth
commandment differs fundamentally from
the other nine in this respect.
It exists to
commemorate God's mightiest deeds in
human history. But here's the thing.
God's mightiest deeds in human history
weren't finished in Exodus 20 or in
Deuteronomy 5. That commandment
therefore is inherently and of its
nature open-ended as it anticipates
God's mighty deeds to come. It's very
different therefore than a command to
not make images of of God. Um which uh
is static and appropriate for all time
or a command to not murder um which we
would expect to be of the same general
nature of application for all time. If
we have a God who's actually working in
redemptive history, we would expect the
fourth commandment, which is a command
to celebrate and to remember the
mightiest of God's deeds to change. And
um that is exactly the sort of thing
that we are going to see in the first
day of the week. Um,
and I'll note this as well, these days
of remembrance always have an anchor uh
to the time in which the mighty divine
deed occurred. Even when the Sabbath
commandment for the seventh day, its
rationale is altered in Deuteronomy 5,
it's still appropriately anchored to the
seventh day. Why? Because it says to
remember when your God with a mighty
hand and outstretched arm redeemed you
from Egypt. What day did that redemption
begin? If not on the eve of the Passover
when God's people slayed the Passover
lamb and then put the blood on their
doorframes and where the Egyptian
firstborns were killed, the Israelite
ones were not. And of course, we know
that that was the 14th day of Nissan, a
seventh day, if not the actual seventh
day of of the week. uh a seventh day in
the succession of um you know 14. Um, so
when we see that Jesus Christ has
victory over Satan's sin and death
itself, rises from the dead on the first
day of the week, the most intuitive,
most natural thing for any Hebrew who
believed in Jesus Christ as savior and
son of God to presume would be this is
now the focal point of our worship. This
has to be. This is the first fruits of a
new resurrection creation. This is God's
ultimate deliverance, not from the
boundaries of a mere hostile nation who
has placed us in servitude. This is the
deliverance of God's people from the
true spiritual enemy who confronted Adam
and Eve in the garden, the serpent
himself who's being crushed by Christ's
heel in the cross. And so with that that
conception in mind, that's the beginning
of, you know, our our argument for first
day worship. Jesus resurrection being
clearly published as having occurred on
the first day of the week in all four
gospels. and uh frequently referenced as
the third day since the Passover um you
know with one Sabbath a weekly Sabbath
intervening um being the consistent
teaching of the New Testament throughout
the gospels and in the epistles. So you
have any any questions for me about that
Miles? No, man. I could listen to that
for another 25 minutes. Um I'm just
sitting there. And I'm like, dude, the
the meat here, the the getting past the
spiritual milk, not dogging on people
that are on spiritual milk. The Bible
obviously clearly states that there's
spiritual milk, but what you're getting
at here is what we would call biblical
theology. And I know people might be
thinking, well, isn't all the Bible or
involving the Bible biblical theology?
Well, no, that the topic of biblical
theology is really looking at the whole
narrative of the Bible and kind of where
things are going. And what you were
hitting at there is that there's a lot
of um what's going on in the Old
Testament that's a lot deeper than what
you may see on the surface. Um there's
the the narrative is kind of going
somewhere and that um creation and
redemption themselves are going
somewhere. It's not just a static thing
in the past, but rather it's telling us
about a lot of stuff that's to come as
well. And so you've kind of hinted at
that. Um, yes. One thing I like that you
mentioned as well is how between Exodus
20:8 and Deuteronomy 5, uh, 13 and 14, I
think it is, um, there's a change in the
form and the spirit of the law. Now,
what do I mean by that, folks? I'm going
to have a video coming out in a couple
weeks that's going to go deeper into
this. Um, Philip Schoff brings this out
in his uh, history of the Christian
religion and he talks about how the
early church rightly recognized that
there was a change in the form and the
spirit between Deuteronomy 5 and Exodus
20. And what he means by that is that in
one place you mentioned this uh, the
Sabbath was to commemorate creation. But
in Deuteronomy it doesn't mention
creation, it mentions redemption, which
shows us the bigger picture of what the
Sabbath was really about. um really
pointing to Christ, Jesus, the
substance. Um but diving deeper into
this, why is understanding the new
creation so important to properly
understanding this specific topic? Um
and what are some of the scriptures that
you would point to for this? Yes. Yes.
You know, it's it's a fantastic
question. And you know, here's my
thought, Miles. Um let's let's plan to
go deep on that question, that new
creation piece. I I'll talk around it a
bit here. Um but let's let's go to those
scriptures in a little bit because you
know one of the things um many seventh
day people have appreciated how powerful
this redemptive historical argument is
for when we ought to worship that God
has always anchored our worship day um
in his mighty deeds in human history or
at the very beginning of history. And
some of these people therefore both 7th
Day Adventists and Worldwide Church of
God um uh devotees uh have have
developed arguments to the effect that
Jesus did not rise on the first day of
the week. And so if you don't mind, I'm
I'm going to try to take us in that
direction for a little bit and then
afterwards we'll talk about how the
Sabbath looks forward to certain things,
how worship days look forward, not only
backward. And we'll talk a little bit
more about new creation. Does that make
sense? Yeah. Go for it. Okay. Well, so
you know, first off, you know, just a
passing observation. You know, I would
just note that seventh day people
understand something of the implications
of what I'm saying because when they
meet on the seventh day, Lord willing,
their worship services are not
fundamentally centered on the mighty
work of God in creating uh the world in
six days and resting on the seventh. it.
They're also not fundamentally orbiting
around, Lord willing, God's redemption
of Israel from the national Egypt.
Hopefully, they're they're worshiping
about the completed work of Jesus Christ
on the cross. And of course, we have
trouble with even the concept of
completed work with the doctrines of the
investigative judgment and things like
that. Um, if you don't know what I
meant, you're listening, then um, forget
it. That's a whole another episode. But
my point is
most people who profess the name of
Christ whether first or seventh day get
it that when we gather together as a
church our focus actually shouldn't be
the things that are mentioned in Exodus
20 in in Deuteronomy 5 with respect to
the fourth commandment. Our focus should
be proclamation of the good news of a a
totally new thing having been
accomplished in Jesus Christ. But once
you admit that, once you say that that
should be the focus of our worship, it
stands to reason and in accordance with
the entire analogy of scripture that the
very day of worship would be altered so
as to commemorate that specific event to
coincide with when that mighty deed of
God, the God man Jesus Christ occurred.
And um and hence we would expect for
there to be a a new sort of worship. And
you you you had mentioned earlier, you
know, a new creation. I mean, the
concept in 2 Corinthians 5:17 that if
anyone is in Christ, he is a new
creature. The old things have passed
away. Behold, new things have come. Now,
all these things are from God who
reconciled us to himself. Here he's
saying something new has come whereby
men have been reconciled to God. Um God
not counting their trespasses against
them and all of that in Christ.
If new things have come, things have
been made new, a mighty deed, an
unprecedented deed of God has occurred
in human history, then the most
intuitive thing for any Bible reader to
to conclude is that we must have worship
that centers around that thing. Um, and
that the timing of it would reflect
that. Um, and and so here's the thing
though, as alluded to, a case is
frequently made uh to the effect that
Jesus did not rise from the dead on the
first day. Um, chiefly from those who
come from either a Messianic Christian
perspective. So, I've seen Messianic
Jews make this argument. I've seen
Worldwide Church of God advocates make
this argument in an article that is on
the internet. I don't know if you want
to put in your um comments or something
for people to look at, but that I've
drawn up is is directed against the
arguments developed by a name a man
named Richard T. Writtenb who's a
worldwide church of God um member. Um uh
but the argument that they make it tends
to center on Matthew 12:40. So I'm just
going to go ahead and read that in this
passage. It says, "For just as Jonah was
three days and three nights in the belly
of the sea monster, so will the Son of
Man be three days and three nights in
the heart of the earth." The argument
that gets made is that this requires
Jesus' body to have been in in the tomb
for 72 hours as if three days and three
nights carried with it a strict 72-hour
time frame. And the argument is that
this can't coincide with the classic uh
versions of the Holy Week where we have
Jesus eating some sort of a pre-passover
replacement Passover meal you could call
it on Thursday evening which would have
been at the beginning of the day we call
Nissan 14. And then Jesus is crucified
on the day of of Nissan 14 which would
be the the day of preparation for the
Passover. And then he's in the grave for
for Saturday. and then rises again on
Sunday. That you you wouldn't have a
full 72 hours in the heart of the earth
if that were the case. And I'm just
curious, Miles, have you ever come
across this sort of thinking? Um, most
definitely. Um, I know there's some
people that view the channel. I don't
know if they necessarily um are getting
this from that individual. Um, but yeah,
I've I've heard that from people outside
of YouTube as well as people that watch
this channel that um sort of use the
same argumentation along those lines.
Perfect. Well, yeah. then a link to that
article will be super helpful and I can
get you one um a little later. But here
here are the sorts of observations that
we have to make. I mean this argument is
entirely misgu misguided. There are
other supportive pieces of evidence that
they try to throw out there. But they
generally take this as the ground for
tossing out the classic, you know, idea
of Holy Week and and what transpired in
it. And then as the alternative theory
goes, typically uh they'll try to argue
that Jesus was rather crucified on a
Wednesday. That um Thursday was um Oh,
I'm about to get jumbled here. Just real
quick. Nope. Crucified on a Thursday.
That
I I've got to get my own diagram up
here. That's what you've got to do. Um
just a second.
No, you're good.
Uh it just a second. Yes. No, it's it's
going to be that sure that Jesus was
crucified allegedly on a on a Wednesday.
On Thursday, there was the feast of
unleavened bread. Friday in between is
kind of a free day where people could do
stuff. And then Saturday is the seventh
day Sabbath. And then Jesus is raised
from the dead. They will we'll usually
argue around 6 p.m. on on Saturday.
crucified around 6 PM or actually buried
and dead at 6 PM on Wednesday, making
for a full 72 hours. Now, there's almost
no evidence, anything you could even
point to to support this scheme. We'll
talk about what they do, but um I want
to say a few things about just the
argument that three days and three
nights it has to equal 72 hours. Um
there's no way that you can read the
Gospels uh as if this were the case.
Many, many, many more scriptures say
that Jesus was going to rise from the
dead on the third day after his death
and crucifixion.
There's no way to be in the grave for 72
hours and rise from the dead on the
third day after you were crucified. It's
just simply mathematically impossible.
You can't do it. And so that sort of
bizarre number crunching that uh often
goes on I should say in 7th day
Adventism and um in such circles is just
it's grossly mistaken. Um but the
biggest problem is the failure to
recognize this common biblical
phenomenon of counting
lengths, distances and time frames
either inclusively or exclusively.
And we do this on such a regular basis,
you know, daytoday that we we miss it.
But we we all count things slightly
differently, especially when it comes to
spanning a partial unit or partial
standard unit of space or time. I'll
give you an example. I asked my kids
recently, if we were to count how many
steps we had on our stairway,
should you count the bottom floor and
should you count the top floor? I'm just
curious what what would you be inclined
to do, Miles? You know, I've never
actually been asked this question
before. And when you're po when you're
posing, I'm like, man, that's kind of
like a deep question to be asking your
kids, you know. Um, and so I I don't
know. Uh, I guess my my just my gut
response would be no, you don't count
them. You don't count them. So, you only
count the ones in between. It was funny
when I asked my kids this. They said if
I'm on the bottom floor, I would count
all the steps in between and the top
floor because it's like I lifted my leg
to get up on that step, but I wouldn't
count the bottom floor.
Just the same I you I think people might
be inclined to say if I'm going down the
stairs, I'm not going to count the the
step I'm standing on at the top and I'm
going to count every step in between and
maybe the bottom floor. Bottom line is
there are three different ways you could
count your stair steps. You could do it
with maximally inclusive would be to
count the bottom floor and the top floor
and every step in between and uh you
know maybe you have an 18, you know,
step uh staircase. Um minimally
inclusively would be to only count the
bottom or count the top depending on
whether you're going up or down. An
exclusive counting would only involve
everything in between.
Well, here's the thing. Uh all of those
are legitimate ways to count something.
Um, you know, one of the things that
arises in Old Testament studies when
you're trying to date events and kind of
line them up with other secular
histories is that Egyptians would
antidate a king's um reign. What that
means is that if a king um began to
reign in succession of his father in
June of 2023,
they would count the next six months as
his first year and then his second year
would begin on New Year's Day and they
would go forward. Well, the Babylonians
did the exact opposite. The new king
began reigning in the middle of the
year. They would count the next six
months as a zero. and then his first
year of his regency would begin on New
Year's following those first six months.
Both of those are reasonable ways of
counting, but of course, you can imagine
how that would muck things up if you're
trying to correlate uh different time
frames. Well, the Bible the Bible
validates both inclusive and exclusive
counting. And that accounts for how
sometimes Jesus stay in the tomb can be
described as three days and three
nights. That's an inclusive way of
describing a burial that spanned three
days and just calling it three full
days. Sometimes it's described
exclusively so that when it says that
Jesus is going to rise from the dead on
the third day, the entire there it's
clear that the time frame within which
he's in in the tomb is going to have to
be shorter than a full 72 hours. And one
of the best ways to see that this is um
those are both perfectly legitimate ways
of describing something is by
considering other time frames in the
Bible. Um I would ask you this, Miles.
How many days was it between
Peter's confession of Christ at Cesaria
Philippi and the transfiguration? Do you
know how many days elapsed in between? I
don't. Yeah. Well, okay, that's fine.
Matthew 17:1 and Mark 9:2 says that six
days elaped elapsed. It says after six
days, you know what they're clearly
trying to do, by the way, is correlate
Jesus going up the high mountain um as
himself a theophony to his disciples
with when Moses goes up in Exodus 24:17.
Oh yeah. Because it says specifically
that the cloud rested for six days and
then it's only on the seventh day that
he gets to go up. Awesome. So that's
clearly what they're trying to do. But
here's the thing. If you read Luke 9:28,
it says that it was about 8 days after
Peter's confession that Jesus went up
the mountain transfiguration.
The one is clearly counting days with um
uh exclusive of the two events between
which you know that the time period
elapses. The other one is counting it
inclusively.
And Luke just has a different purpose.
He has a different aim. His aim is he
wants you to see Jesus transfiguration
as an anticipation of Jesus resurrection
glory which will also happen on an
eighth day. That's the first day of the
week in Luke 24:1. He's trying to say
this is the glorious Lord that is going
to be revealed more fully on thee. the
big eighth day, the first day, which is
uh so emphasized all throughout the New
Testament. But the point is two
different ways of counting something are
perfectly legitimate. And for the
purposes of an author to make different
theological or typological points, you
might use the one or the other.
That this is the case is just painfully
obvious all throughout the Bible when
you actually start reading it.
Seriously. Esther, for example,
instructs her companions to fast for
three days and three nights before she
goes and encounters the king with a
special request. But it says, so that's
Esther 4:16, you know, fast for three
days, night and day. But it says in in
chapter 5:1, on the third day she went
to the king. So she's going to the king
in the midst of this fasting
intercession on the third day,
overlapping with some of it. And so we
can we can both describe things as ex
excuse me as as three full days and
three nights when the big pivotal event
occurs within that time frame as opposed
to fully and completely after it. Same
thing occurs with Joseph's brothers. It
says in uh Genesis 42:17 that um he had
them imprisoned for three days and it
says in 42:18 that he released them on
the third day. In my article I have like
20 instances of this sort of phenomenon.
But my point is this. There is no
contradict contradiction of the
traditional straightforward passion
narrative that has Jesus crucified on a
Friday in the grave all of Saturday and
rising early on Sunday. None at all. And
you know the only thing I would observe
further is you know we only need to ask
what are the what is the theological
intent of Matthew in so describing the
time frame of Jesus burial as three days
and three nights. um why does he elect
to use this sort of inclusive time frame
to describe it that way? And I would
submit that the answer is
straightforward. First of all, to allude
to Jonah's three days and three nights
in the heart of the earth. But that only
pushes the question back a little bit
further. Why did you know Jonah describe
his descent um into the abyss in the
fish that way? And the answer is to
connect both Jesus and Jonah with the
third day of creation. There we have
three days all in succession described
as a day and a night, an evening and a
morning. And what happens the third day
of creation? Well, Earth is raised up
above the chaos of the seas. And not
only that does dry land appear, and of
course, men are made of dust. And so,
these two men are brought up from the
abyss, you could say. um from death to
life. But on the third day, God, it's
the first time he creates a living thing
into material creation. He all of the
seedbearing plants begin to spring forth
and and and life is now on the earth. So
Jesus third day resurrection is
described as happening as a three-day
and three night thing to allude to this
work of creation and uh for it to be
apparent that um Jesus is the ultimate
sort of third day uh injection of life
into reality and um rising again. So I
hope that's all clear enough. Does that
Yeah, man. Again, there's just like so
much meat there. Um, I could listen to
this for like another hour. These sort
of like the third day connection that's
so important there. But there's
something else that you said that I
think is really important. Um, that I
think is really important as well to
distinguish between what we're saying
and what Seventh Day Adventists are
saying. Yeah. In Adventism, there tends
to be this sort of thinking and idea
that there's almost like a mystically
divine aspect to the 24hour rotation
around the sun of Saturday. And you said
that it's about more than the day, but
what the worship is centered around.
Yes, the worship is centered around the
substance. It's deeper than the day. The
day points to something. The day is not
the substance.
And I think that that's a really big
difference between what we're saying and
what they're saying. Which kind of segus
here perfectly into the next question of
what you're saying then is that the
Sabbath was not only for national
Israel. Correct. Yes. I would Yeah. The
the creation Sabbath was instituted for
mankind to have a foretaste of eternity.
I'll go at that at some length. Um,
Miles, I hate to keep suggesting that
maybe you mind if I just touch on two
other alleged proofs that Jesus didn't
rise from the dead on the first day.
Absolutely. Go for it. Well, another
proof, and this is just so painfully
misguided. Um, it's it's hard to take it
seriously, but it would be hard for a
reader of these sorts of articles uh to
realize how misguided it is. But in
Matthew 28:1, it says that now after the
Sabbath, this is what your English
translation would read. I'm I'm reading
the NASB95.
Um says, "Now after the Sabbath, as it
began to dawn toward the first day of
the week, Mary Magdalene and the other
Mary came to look at the grave." Um
those who want to argue for a full 72
hours of Jesus in the grave and two
distinct Sabbaths occurring in the same
week will point out that in fact,
Matthew 28:1 says this. Now, after the
Sabbaths plural, uh, the Greek word
sabatone, where they infer, therefore
that Matthew is telling you that Jesus
didn't rise from the dead until after
not only the seventh day Sabbath
occurred, but also earlier that week on
Thursday, the the feast of unleven bread
Sabbath occurred. Um, this is just
terribly misguided. And the reason why
is because the word Sabbath in Greek um
would typically uh be found in the
plural rather than the singular even
when it's um sense is singular. That's
weird. We don't have this phenomenon in
English. I'll just point out that
several Greek words are like this. The
word for birthday in in Greek is
typically in the plural. And why this
is, you know, would maybe seem to be
that that day is is thought of as
significant and recurring. So you have
your your birthdays and you know when is
when when's your birthdays? Mile Miles.
I mean, we would never say that, but
there were multiple words like that in
the Greek language. In fact, all
throughout the gospels, like when it
says, you know, they were examining or
testing Jesus on the Sabbath in Matthew
12:15 and 10 and following it, every
time it says that on the Sabbaths is
what it says. And yet, it's clear that a
specific definite Sabbath is in view.
So, this argument is birthed from
incredible
um uh just ignorance of the Greek
language. And it also is problematic in
the very same verse because as it goes
on, it says it began to dawn toward the
first day of the week. most aren't aware
that what that really says is began to
dawn toward the first of Sabbaths. Um
the word for Sabbath would would double
as the word for week. Um it you know it
was the culmination of seven days and so
you would just call the week a Sabbath
or a seven. And um there it says it
began to dawn toward the first day of
the week neon sabatone. Again, Sabbaths
plural. And no, nobody is mistaken that
the first day on which, you know, Jesus
tomb is found empty is the first of
multiple Sabbaths. I don't even know
what that would mean, but it's clear
that Sabbath is meant to be singular
there. Um, I guess to be honest, we're
going to read into the words here. Uh, a
far more impressive sort of reading
would be that there's a double entandra
going on when it says that it began to
dawn toward the first day of the week.
um that you could read that as obviously
the first of, you know, a a seven-day
period or a first or highest or anti-ype
of all Sabbaths, calling the first day
something like the the first of of
Sabbaths the um the antitype to which
the types are pointing. And you know,
there have been some in in the history
of of uh theology who have um understood
it that way. But I'll just say this,
that is a better speculative reading of
Matthew 28:1 than that there were two
Sabbaths that elapsed between um, you
know, Jesus death and resurrection.
Um,
I, you know, I'll tell you, I'll stop
there. If anyone wants more on that
topic in great depth, believe me, there
are great depths in in the article link
that I'll pass on to you. Um, but uh, I
I will leave that to others. But the key
is this. There's no way to read the
biblical gospels. And honestly, the
advocates of seventh day day um
resurrection view admit this. There's no
way to read any one of the biblical
gospels individually and arrive at this
concept that Jesus rose from the dead on
the seventh day. The simple
straightforward reading of it would be
that Jesus was crucified on a Friday.
That a Sabbath, a high Sabbath that was
at once the seventh day Sabbath and the
the feast of unleven bread elapsed in
between and Jesus rose from the dead on
the first day. And that is your
three-day period where these momentous
events occurred. So, I'll leave it at
that. That's interesting, man. I I
haven't met very many SDAs. So, I've
talked with hundreds, probably thousands
honestly at this point over the course
of really my whole life, but in 10 years
now of being engaged with them, not
necessarily always in YouTube, but um in
other avenues, I haven't come across a
ton who have a view of like a seventh
day resurrection. The argument they
typically like to use for their view is
to say Jesus kept the Sabbath while he
was in death,
that he was resting on the seventh day.
Um, and that there's really no basis
behind the idea of the day that Christ
resurrected being a day of worship when
really I think the primary issue roots
in the fact that Jesus was not resting
in the tomb. Jesus was working for our
redemption. Um Paul tells us, and you
mentioned this a little bit earlier
about the first fruits, um in 1
Corinthians 15, that if Christ is not
raised from the dead, then our faith is
in vain and we're still dead in our
sins. We were not Jesus was not resting
in the tomb, folks. Jesus was working at
accomplishing our redemption. He rested
when he exited the tomb, entering into
his mediatorial rest from his state of
humiliation to his exaltation, having
completed that work of redemption. And
so I want to transition now here to some
a a couple common claims before then we
look at some quotes, if you will, um,
and just hear your response, what you
got. Well, Miles, here's the thing.
Yeah, I know. I know that what you said
was so fantastic and you know I I I
really want to double down on this
concept the SDA argument that kind of
the topology that they see is that Jesus
is Sabbathkeeping in the tomb on the
seventh day. Um and you're making the
very important point that Jesus was um
uh that that that that wasn't his
victorious rest in that moment. And I'm
wondering if if I might be able to to
provide something of even deeper perhaps
somewhat more long- winded um uh making
of the same point. Do you appre would
that be okay? That would be excellent.
Okay. Well, what this the groundwork
that has to be lane is that one of the
mysterious things about all biblical
holy days is that they were never only
intended to commemorate the past. uh
they were always as well intended to
look forward to esqueological events in
the future. And just to solidify that
point, I want to make it with respect to
a variety of um of the Old Testament
holy days. Passover. You know, it's good
news that Israel was redeemed from the
destroying angel, but the fact that you
have to keep doing the Passover is also
a painful reminder there's still a
destroying angel out there. And that um
that the Passover lamb that was slain in
1500 BC roughly wasn't sufficient to
stave off the just penalty and death
that is due to us all. as we're just as
defiled as the Egyptians. So the
Passover looks forward to and needs
fulfillment in a final Passover lamb.
And of course, you know, first
Corinthians 5:13, Jesus is our Passover
lamb, unleavened bread. We you would
note um as well, you are discarding this
old thing and a new a new thing is being
brought in, a new beginning that looks
forward of course to Christ as well who
um ushers in a new creation. first
fruits, look forward to Jesus
resurrection. Pentecost, the 50th day
after the Passover when the law was
given. Uh it's kind of problematic
because you only give law to a sinful
people. Um it looks forward to a day
when we won't just have law, but when
we'll have the spirit of God and the
nations will have the spirit of God. Um
so that there would be masses who keep
it. um you know these days are looking
forward to something and I just I want
to emphasize you know this this
esqueological focus this future focus of
Old Testament holy days it's not even
hard to see how much it orbits around
the first day um of the holy days that
we've mentioned in Israel you know
Passover is on a 14th day and transition
to a 15th day that's that's a first day
after two successions of seven feast of
unleven Bread is the 15th day. That's
first day after two successions of
seven. First fruits is supposed to be on
the first weekly, first day of the week
after unleavened bread and Passover.
Pentecost being as it is on a 50th day
is going to be a first day after seven
successions of seven. Feast of trumpets
supposed to be on the first day of the
seven seventh month. Booths begins on a
15th day which again is a first after
two successions of seven and its great
and highest day is on an eighth day
after that. So you know even on on this
front once we have the concept that
there's an esqueological focus of holy
days um we would look everywhere in the
old testament and be anticipating
something momentous to occur on a first
day. Um, even some of the major
ceremonies of the old covenant, you
know, the ironic priests had to undergo
an 8day ritual, essentially a death and
resurrection sequence where on the other
side of it, they're clothed with
priestly garments and can go into God's
house. Um, on an eighth day,
circumcision being applied on the eighth
day as a sort of sign and symbol of
cleansing of the flesh. um e you know
even prophetic references that you know
Ezekiel's temple talks about a priest
who shall um from the eighth day onward
that that's implying he under goes
through the same ironic 8day death
resurrection sequence um in the future
and again a first day will mark out a
new type of worship um with this many
first first day references in the old
testament
it is not at all hard to say first off
that we have the basic elements of a
typological prophecy that redemption is
going to center on the first day. It is
such a recurring theme and it's just as
powerful, at least as powerful as other
New Testament prophecies such as that
Jesus would go down into Egypt with, you
know, obviously a a reference to Hosea
11:1 and back of that, you know,
prophecy in Numbers. But um we have
enough material to go this thing is
being prophesied in the typical way that
things are being prophesied. But I want
to talk more about this concept of the
first day in prophecy. You pointed out
that seventh day Adventists will argue
that Jesus was resting on the seventh
day when intombed and in that sense
somehow validating it. Well, consider
this. God rests on the seventh day um at
the completion and as a sort of a
refreshment in the work of his hands in
the six days prior. The implication in
Genesis 2 is that man who's made in
God's image is also going to have to
work for a long season taking dominion
of the earth subduing it filling it all
of it at which at some point eventually
he's going to enter into rest from his
labors. He the terminus of his labors
will have come. And to point man to that
esqueological end, man is to live out
his work week and rest on the seventh
day repeatedly as an anticipation that
he would enter into rest uh
esquetologically.
Now here's the very interesting thing
about this. If there's one thing that
that would tell us about when man's work
would be completed,
we would be certain that his work would
not be completed on the seventh day.
Why? Because man is instructed to always
work six days and rest on the seventh.
resting on the seventh, although a rest
from his normal labors, is a
commemorative rest and an act of
obedience to God's law. Man's work can't
be finished until after the seventh day
when he's rested as an act of obedience,
passive obedience to God's law. And
therefore, the only days in which this
new creation completion of man's work
could occur would have to be days other
than the seventh. And something very
close to this is the argument being made
in Hebrews chapter 4. Um the entire Old
Testament was really a story about
mankind completing their work, led by
some hero in doing so, and then
hopefully entering into God's rest.
Joshua was a foretaste of that when he
went and conquered the promised land.
But the problem was people didn't rest
after that. They incurred judgment and
um they weren't finished. And so the
argument in Hebrews 4 is that David
looked forward to a new day when a man
like Joshua will actually usher in
eternal rest at the completion of his
work. And so in chapter 4 7 to10 it says
he again fixes a certain day. Um he's
going to quote Psalm he's already quoted
Psalm 95. uh where God says today um
saying through David after so long a
time just as has been said before today
if you hear his voice do not harden your
hearts for if Joshua of course the Greek
word there is Jesus you know Jesus and
Joshua being the same name if Joshua had
given them rest that's a general word
for rest he would not have spoken of
another day after that so there remains
a Sabbath day's rest for the people of
God for the one who has entered his
rest. That's a man. Jesus has himself
also rested from his works. He wasn't
doing that on the seventh day. He was on
the seventh day buried in the tomb. And
uh in in the midst of his passive
obedience to God's law, which required
death and um therefore this new day
can't be the seventh day. It is the
first day when Jesus obedience to the
full was completed and he is vindicated
and resurrected in glory. And so I my
long- winded explanation uh to Miles is
that I would use that SDA argument
against them. Okay. So Jesus is keeping
the law on the seventh day, but that's a
prerequisite to him entering his human
rest and his work being completed.
That's a prerequisite to him entering
into eternal glory. It can't be the day
on which Jesus work was completed and
vindicated.
Man, again, there's just like so much
meat there that as you're saying stuff
like other connections are coming to
mind. Um I'm I'm thinking about things
you said really around the eighth day
and how prior to um well like leaving
Adventism
having no real understanding of this and
how prevalent it actually is in
scripture. You mentioned the first
fruits earlier which Paul mentions Jesus
being the first fruits of the
resurrection in 1 Corinthians 15. Well
the original reader would have obviously
understood what he was referring to. It
wasn't just like poetic language. He's
referring to what's stated in the Old
Testament. Well, if we go to Leviticus
23, the Sabbath chapter, ironically, we
have the feast of first fruits being
described with Jesus, which is obviously
pointing to Jesus. But something else
that's interesting that's pointed out in
Leviticus 23 at the end of the chapter
is that there was to be a holy
convocation on the the the text says the
first and the eighth day. So, it uses
both in one spot. Um just some others
because I've I've compiled a list over
time. Um of all the the eight motifs um
that are connected with redemption,
recreation, etc. Um you've got
circumcision. Uh the mother was
ceremonially unclean until the eighth
day. Uh until the eighth day, the
firstborn of cattle that belonged to the
Lord were not offered or received by
him. Um on the eighth day, but not
before, animals were accepted in
sacrifice. On the eighth day, the
consecration of Aaron and his sons was
completed. On the eighth day, the
cleansing of leprosy took place. The
cleansing of issues took place. Um, on
the eighth day, atonement was made of
the defiled Nazerite. The dedication of
the temple uh was on the eighth day.
Like you mentioned earlier, Ezekiel
43:26 and 27, the priests were to offer
burnt offerings on the eighth day and
then God accepts his people. Um, the
fact uh or the the feast of tabernacles
was to be celebrated the fifth tenth
which corresponds to the eighth day. Um
the 15th day, the first day after 7* 7
days or seven weeks, which corresponds
with the eighth day after seven days was
distinguished as the feast of weeks.
You've got the year of Jubilee, um which
was the 15th year and not uh and not the
49th, which was the last of the
sabbatical years. And this 15th year,
the first year after the sabbatical year
of seven weeks corresponds to the eighth
day. Yeah, that's right. I mean, eight
again and again and again. And of course
what this speaks to is something new.
And you think about the explicit
prophecies like in Psalm 118, you know
that you stone that the builders have
rejected and um you know it will
nevertheless be raised up as the chief
cornerstone and you know this is the day
that the Lord has made. Um this is
looking forward to a new mighty work
that trumps every prior work of God from
creation to the various foreshadowings
of redemption in the Old Testament. And
you know this is you know obviously
we're reading Hebrews 4 and it's talking
about a Joshua who has entered his rest
and on that basis there remains a
Sabbath day's rest obviously very
specific word in Hebrews 4:8 um
sabatismos a Sabbath day's rest for the
people of God that correlates with the
work of this Joshua um there's one thing
we know for certain it is not the
seventh day uh it's going to have to
correlate with when Jesus Christ rose
from the dead and Um, so when people
ask, you know, is there the Sabbath
command for Christians? Not only is that
Hebrews 4:8 text rather powerful, but I
would also note that in Hebrews 10:25,
um, there we have a generic, I think
most people read it as a generic command
for the people of God to not forsake
gathering together. And you know, the
concept that this would be done
rhythmically or regularly, um, it's it's
actually really hard to imagine
any sense in which that could be
fulfilled with mere impromptu
gatherings. Um, but but here's an
important insight. The entire problem in
Hebrews is that people are going back
from Christian modes of worship and
Christian theology to old um he Hebrew
ways of worshiping and um viewing the
world. Uh they're Judaizing to use the
language of Galatians.
If the Christians who are commanded to
not forsake gathering together uh were,
you know, or these these people lapsing
into back into Judaism were being
reminded to not forsake gathering with
Christians.
Um it implies that the Christian day of
gathering couldn't have been Saturday
because these people turning back to the
Mosaic forms of worship and worshiping
on Saturday would be indistinguishable
for from Christians at that point. The
command of the Hebrew of Hebrews 10:25
implies a different day of worship. The
only reasonable candidate for it is the
one that Christians have historically
been worshiping uh uh you know in for
2,000 years. And of course we find them
worshiping uh throughout the New
Testament, which is the first day. So,
I'd argue that that Hebrews 10:25 is
actually a a much stronger proof text
for the perpetuity of a fourth
commandment, a Sabbath command for a
holy convocation like we read about in
in Leviticus 23, the Sabbath chapter.
Um,
because because the the verse implies
that the Christians have a distinct time
of gathering that is unmistakable uh
from those who are lapsing back into
Judaism.
Interesting. Um, I want to ask you about
specifically Hebrews 4:9 because
Adventists love that verse. Adventists
love to proof text Hebrews 4:9 to say,
"See, there remains a Sabbath rest for
the people of God." And he just
mentioned the the creation, the original
creation account, which was the seventh
day. So, he's talking about the seventh
day there. So, my question is, um, if
it's still binding, yeah. Doesn't the
Bible say the seventh day, Saturday
specifically? Yeah. Well, I'll say a few
things. Number one, it doesn't say there
remains the Sabbath day's rest, which I
might expect if the um seventh day
argument uh were even plausible in this
passage. But second of all, the ground
for why there remains a Sabbath day's
rest for the people of God. Something
inaugurated by and initiated by a man is
supplied in the next verse. For the one
who has entered his rest, that's Jesus,
has himself also rested from his works
as God did. And he did not rest from his
works on the seventh day. He rested from
his works in the resurrection. That's
the explanation supplied by the text.
Searching in Hebrews chapter 4 backwards
to find references to creation when you
have a clear explanatory conjunction in
verse 9 itself.
um is is uh grasping its straws. Um the
passage supplies the rationale for why
we have a Sabbath day's rest, a new
Sabbath day's rest for the people of
God. And he wouldn't furthermore even
have to make this point if he were
simply agreeing with the Judaizers that
of course we all worship on the seventh
day. It it's really out of place at that
point. Nor would it be clear how or why
he's having to compel them to not cease
gathering. Um, of course they want to
gather. They just want to do it on the
seventh day. Um, but that's not a
Christian gathering in the New Testament
sense. And so th those are just a couple
of um reasons why I would take issue
with their point. Um, but Miles, do you
mind if I I just set set one more point
out there when we talk about the future
and Yes. Okay. So, we've talked about
how holy days in the Bible have both a
past and a future reference. They they
point us to God's mighty deeds in the
past which are themselves foretastes and
anticipations of something that he's
going to do in the consummation of all
things. Really significant um is this
the Lord's supper is the only New
Testament sacrament that we're given to
which there is attached um the concept
of a memorial or or a remembrance. So we
think about you know in all of the last
supper events you know do this as a
memorial for me. Um so whatever this
sacrament is it is tied to remembering
right and of course that's at the heart
of the fourth commandment you know to
remember um remember the day and
remember God's works on the day creation
and redemption um creation of the world
and redemption from Egypt in those Old
Testament texts. What is noteworthy is
that the only day on which we actually
see the Lord's supper observed in the
New Testament, it is always the first
day. And if the preeeminent sign of
remembrance is being observed on the
first day and the fourth commandment is
all about remembering God's mighty deeds
of creation and redemption. That's a
pretty powerful argument for the
conclusion that the first day is the
focal point of the fourth commandment.
And I I would just observe on
resurrection Sunday when Jesus is
walking with the two disciples,
Cleopus and the other one unnamed. We're
told specifically in Luke 24:30-32
that when he, that's Jesus, had reclined
at the table with them, he took the
bread and blessed it, and breaking it,
he began giving it to them. Then their
eyes were opened and they recognized
him, and he vanished from their sight.
And they said to one another, "We are uh
were not our hearts burning within us."
While he was speaking to us on the road,
while he was explaining the scriptures
to us, what do we see on resurrection
Sunday? Jesus himself
engaging in this meal with the four
standard verbs in all of the gospel
accounts of the last supper in their
exact order that he takes the bread,
blesses the bread, breaks the bread and
distributes the bread and then a miracle
happens. Their eyes are open. Obviously,
the point here that Luke is trying to
make is that um Jesus uh is by his
spirit present at the Lord's supper
doing mighty things to accompany his
preaching of the word. And the fact that
he does this on the first day, the fact
that later in the New Testament in Acts
chapter 20, we find Paul on the first
day breaking bread with the people. This
would be the clearest indication to
anyone who's committed to remembering
God's mighty deeds as an application of
the fourth commandment that the first
day is the time for fulfilling and the
time for taking seriously that moral
commandment.
Man, that's good. you you brought up a
really good connection point too there
um not just with with spiritual presence
of Christ um at the supper but um
specifically in regards to the
connection point between uh the supper
being tied to remembering the death of
Christ whereas the Lord's day is a
remembrance of the resurrection of
Christ two regularly recurring things
while the Lord's day is not necessarily
a sacrament um it's a memorial that's
that's why we're there It's all about
Jesus. That's that's why we're there.
And of course with the Lord's supper,
there's also a uh an anticipation
element. Do this until I come. And so
all of the stuff that you would expect
to be done, you know, expect, you know,
a holy day to center on is encapsulated
in the Lord's supper and we find it
appearing on the first day. It's a
powerful indication that the fourth
commandment is so so to be kept.
So, I have one last question before we
transition into looking over a couple
quotes that are kind of central
specifically to Seventh Day Adventism
that I want to get your thoughts on. Um,
and that's in regards to Revelation 110.
Yeah. The phrase the Lord's Day. The
Adventist church is insistent. I
actually have a friend uh I think he's
watching um who received a pamphlet
today from an Adventist uh media outlet
um that was about the truth of the
Lord's day and how the Lord's day in
Revelation 11:0 I get comments about
this all the time um is in reference to
the Jewish Sabbath. Can you expound upon
that? What is the Lord's day in
Revelation 11:0? Yeah. Um you know, I'll
mention a few things. There's no
instance in which the Sabbath is called
by that name in the Septuagent, the
Greek translation of the the Old
Testament, where it's ever called the
Lord's day.
That that would be the first good reason
to doubt such an explanation. Um, a much
better way to so describe it uh would be
simply anything from the Lord's Sabbath
or uh uh to simply call it the Sabbath
itself. Um, this is not a compelling
argument because it's not an unambiguous
way or even the most natural way to
denote the Sabbath. Instead, the
particular Greek word that is used here,
um, cury, you know, from cur curios, um,
is only elsewhere used in the New
Testament to describe the Lord's supper.
And the thought therefore that this like
the Lord's supper being tied directly to
a momentous event in Jesus own ministry
at the last supper the the strongest
explanation is going to be that what we
have a reference to here is the to the
day on which Christ rose from the dead
and what do we see on this initial
vision but John confronted by the
resurrected Christ proclaiming his own
resurrection. I am the one who was and
is um this this one who was briefly
taken but is is conquered and who is in
resurrection glory. So there's simply no
basis for that conclusion. Um in fact
it's it's undermined by the fact that
there would have been easy ways to
identify this day as the Sabbath. Um but
that opportunity is entirely foregone.
Yeah. So essentially it's the grammar.
The grammar is what refutes that. Um yes
the specific words used. I mean you know
it it the the other places where that
particular um adjective is used is with
resp with respect to things belonging to
Caesars's you know who obviously was
regarded as a lord. Yeah. Um it it's
just not a typical word um in uh Greek
Christian usage uh Greek Hebrew usage to
describe a a unique possession of
Yahweh.
It's good stuff. Um right. Yeah, that's
uh that's good. So, I want to transition
here now to a couple of quotes. Like I
mentioned, um folks, you can start
sending questions through. We're going
to try and get through these um
relatively quickly. Um, but you can
start sending your questions through as
per usual. If you will put a Q in front
of your question so it doesn't get lost
in the mix. Um, and we'll try to get to
some of those before we uh before we
close out tonight. But I want to read
this first one here. This is from um
Ellen White
and she says in evangelism on page 234,
quote, "The change of the Sabbath is the
sign or mark of the authority of the
Rish.
Those who understanding the claims of
the fourth commandment choose to observe
the false Sabbath in place of the true
are thereby paying homage to that power
by which alone it is commanded. The mark
of the beast is the papal Sabbath which
has been accepted by the world in the
place of the day of God's appointment.
in worship is is worshiping on Sunday
the mark of the authority of the Roman
Catholic Church or the papal Sabbath?
Absolutely not. It's just a fascinating
claim and not on account of its
brilliance, but just on account of how
many baseless assumptions there are
within it. Um, you know, here's the
thing. Um, you know, Adventism inherits
uh an esquetological
perspective or method um that was common
at the at the um at the Reformation,
which was, you know, a historicist view
of prophecy unfolding, you know, chapter
by chapter in Revelation through human
history. And um here's the thing, you
know, as a reformed person, you know, I
can appreciate um you know, the the
disdain that uh Adventists have, you
know, historically had for the Roman
church. There are really terrible things
that the Roman church did. No doubt
about it. But the problem is that um
whereas reformed people are going to see
continual development, positive
theological development in the history
of the church, um you know, Adventism
flirts with the sort of restorationist
view that it's almost as if the church
ceased to exist on planet Earth, but for
the teeniest, tiniest re remnant for
some, you know, 1700 years until Samuel
Miller came along and, you know, Ellen
white and you name it. Um, and of course
they'll try to
commandeer the Waldenzians to being kind
of their precursors and stuff like that
and other smaller groups. But, you know,
it's really hard to not see how this uh
doesn't represent exactly the sort of
thing that Jesus said wouldn't occur,
which is the gates of hell prevailing
against the church. Um you know as
reformed people we know wonderful things
occurred in terms of theological
development um all throughout church
history and more precise views of the
atonement were being reached by men like
anelm in in the medieval period. Um you
know even just uh incredible powerful
theological argumentation on the use of
images and worship in the seventh and
eth centuries are being developed. Um,
so we don't tend to see uh a time when
just everybody was off their rocker.
There are things that Thomas Aquinus
said that we would consider to be uh
powerful advances in in in careful and
precise theology um despite, you know,
some, you know, blaring failures. Um
that's just a fundamental difference
between Adventists and the reformed. And
this quote really speaks to that. Um, if
worshiping on Sunday is the mark of the
beast,
um, you know, what percentage of
Christianity
are you like what percentage of
Christianity since the time of the
apostles are strictly hellbound? I mean,
it's it's the church disappeared if that
view is true.
Yeah. Yeah. And they're going to tell
you, you know, well, it hasn't been
issued yet because it's going to be at a
point where a national Sunday law is
issued by a three-fold union between
apostate Protestantism and Roman
Catholicism and spiritualism. And it's
once this enactment comes down, it's at
that point it will be the mark of the
beast. This was only applicable for this
last day present truth people. Uh you
kind of hinted at that a little bit with
the restorationist sort of ideologies.
Um, but that's kind of the argument that
they'd probably bring to that is, well,
this wasn't applicable then. It was
applicable for the last time people. So
all those people before they were saved
in ignorance. Yes. Very familiar with
these sorts of arguments. And to be
honest, you know, I wouldn't even call
that an argument. It's kind of an an
apologetic, you know, uh, rolling back
what the quote says. Because here's the
thing. If if it's fundamentally beastly
to worship on the first day in in in the
se, you know, the seven-year trib, not
seven-year tribulation, but in the great
tribulation that they anticipate. Um,
what what is the moral change that
transpired there that renders that so
terrible um versus in the intervening
years? I mean, this is apparently one of
the things God is the most concerned
about. um which I would just really want
to emphasize and all that I had
previously said about you know the the
fourth commandment being something that
Christians are um you know called to
observe.
I absolutely entertain the justification
of Christians who have not come to that
depth of you know insight about the
scriptures because it's by grace alone
through faith alone. But on the face of
it, this is the sort of thing that cult
leaders say that would really shock and
scare just about anybody reading it. The
way, you know, a quote like this loans
itself to being read is that
it's simple. There's a choice to observe
the false Sabbath in the place of the
true and that when you you do the
former, you're paying homage to
something beastly.
It's just hard to reconcile that with,
you know, the the kind of um, you know,
explanation that you've supplied, which
you're right, is this exact sort of
thing that you're going to hear. And it
also makes us all a little bit antsy
about Ellen White's theology in general
appropriately if that's all we had. But
then when we have everything else, we're
even more concerned about it because
these are the kinds of things that that
Herbert W. Armstrong would do and uh
they're shocking. um you know he was
obviously notorious for kind of cryptic
predictions that the Lord would return
at certain times that the apologists
will they'll go well you know he wasn't
really saying Jesus would return then or
you know he was saying something
slightly different and of course that is
an endemic feature of um Adventism since
the great disappointment 84 1843 um that
Ellen White is kind of the supreme
apologist for explaining what really
happened there not to take us off off
track too more.
Yeah, I I agree, man. It's just and I
think Adventists oftenimes too struggle
with what I'm going to say here. Um, but
regardless, it's the facts. The claim
that's being made is a historical claim.
So, I don't know if you're familiar,
they're more along the lines of like a
nuda scriptor or a biblicism, sort of
like a Bible and me under the tree,
we've got the Holy Spirit type idea.
Um, and because of that, anytime that
you reference history, they're going to
say, "Well, tell me from the Bible,"
which that's not true. They don't
believe every historical fact. They
don't believe Abraham Lincoln existed
because of the Bible. So, they'll accept
certain historical things, but when it
comes to this, all of a sudden, they
want to just say, "Well, no, it has to
be from the Bible." Well, this is a
historical claim, and all of the
historical record is against this idea
as well. Um, depending on the Adventists
you talk to, you'll get Constantine
changed the Sabbath or you'll get the
Pope changed the Sabbath or if you're uh
lucky, you'll get someone who thinks
Constantine was a pope and he changed
the Sabbath. Um, but we have records
long before this in both the East and
the West, which is important in that
discussion. Um, it's just unquestionable
there. There's no um disagreement on
this. This was universally understood.
Um you can read early history sources um
for the reasoning behind this. And
really what you were saying in regards
to the reformation building upon what
was already present which is very
different than restoring something
that's not there at all is the fact that
the reformers built upon what the early
church was saying about the Sabbath is
that it is the eighth day motif. It is
the day of uh the new creation being
inaugurated. These types of things. So
yes, the day of worship, the day of the
Lord's supper, all of those things. Yes.
Yes. And you know I recall you know um I
did a I don't have a reference on hand
you know I did a um church class on 7th
day Adventism just to you know inform
interested parishioners but you know I
recall reading a quote from um Ellen
White about the Protestant creeds and
confessions being um you know dry musty
old things. And I just thought, my
goodness, like you
you are clearly not giving a very
charitable read to the Westminster
Confession or Shorter Catechism or
surely not the H Highleberg. These
things are just such awesome summaries
of scripture. Um just glorious glorious
things, you know, that again, you know,
point us back to the scriptures as our
highest rule of faith and practice. But
um without negating the very important
work of teachers in the church in
theological development over time and
you know it's it's super sad I that
groups like 7th day Adventism which had
this sort of ahistoricism
actually kind of have more of a mono
historicism that you know all
interesting theological developments
orbit around a single individual or you
know couple of individuals obviously
Joseph Smith and Brigham Young or you
Miller and White. Um, you know, part
part of the problem with Worldwide
Church of God is that Herbert W. or
Armstrong really did more or less stand
alone and had no successor and disbanded
in many respects. But but
what happens when you think that way is
your guy or your girl become um they
become the focal point of biblical
prophecy and themselves something like
biblical prophets. And as far as you're
trying to get from the authority of a
Roman church and you know pap sort of
guide, you actually have one in your
midst who's you know the end all be all.
And um it just it is such a a
frightening portrait of the biblical
concept of selfdeception. Um to be that
anti-apple and to end up with someone
who functionally has that same role.
That's so true. I say it all the time.
Um they've traded the Roman magisterium
for Ellen White. Um she functions the
same way. It's just not a um a sea of
cardinals, if you will. Um it's just a a
single individual. So let's look at this
second quote here. Uh I want to get your
thoughts again. She says, this is also
from the same book on the next page,
evangelism, page 235.
in the light of truth has been presented
to you or if sorry if the light of truth
has been presented to you revealing the
Sabbath of the fourth commandment and
showing that there is no foundation in
the word of God for Sunday observance
and yet you still cling to the false
Sabbath refusing to keep holy the
Sabbath which God calls my holy day. You
receive the mark of the beast. When does
this take place? When you obey the
decree that commands you to cease from
labor on Sunday and worship God, while
you know that there's not a word in the
Bible showing Sunday to be other than a
common working day, you consent to
receive the mark of the beast and refuse
the seal of God. Yeah. Two things. Is
there no biblical evidence for this? I
know you went over some of this earlier,
but what are some biblical places you
would point to for this? And is the
Sabbath the seal of God? Yeah. Yeah. You
know, okay. So, so first off, I I just I
want to emphasize how especially to an
undiscerning Christian. Um
just how powerful this sort of thing
will sound, especially when you maybe
you quote Exodus 20 or like Sabbath is
clearly seventh day. You show four or
five other verses. Um there's no verse
that says in these words, you know, the
Sabbath day hath been changed to X Y or
Z day. Um you know this it's the sort of
thing when my grandfather fell into um
the worldwide church of God. It's exact
that was kind of the sticker. Clearly
the church has been so badly wrong for
so long when you have these clear
references to the seventh day. And I
want to just say first off, this I hope
is something that we take as an
imperative as Protestants to actually do
uh engage the the work of religion that
that we engage in on the Lord's Day,
which is to search the scriptures daily
to see if things are true and to
acquaint ourselves with them. My grandpa
being raised Roman Catholic
was a sitting duck. I hate to put it
that way, but there was no discipline of
of scripture reading and understanding
uh with the aid not of one one
theologian in in church history, but
countless generations of theologians in
church history and and building upon
their insights. There's nothing like
that. But that's more like the
Protestant ideal. Now, is she correct?
Obviously not. I've already talked about
the fundamental biblical principle that
holy days are anchored down to the
biggest events in human history where
God's saving work is manifest is a
creative recreative redemptive work is
manifest. The Bible's unambiguous.
That's the first day. Um it is a time
for remembrance of God's mighty deeds
and anticipation of the future. The
Lord's supper, the focal point of
Christian remembrance is on celebrated
on the first day uh more than once. Um
Jesus Christ preaches two sermons on the
first day of his resurrection. It's
followed by an eighth day visit of his
disciples to impress the same truths
upon them. Followed by a 50th day
sermon, inaugural sermon on Pentecost
Sunday to Christians demanding they
remember the Christ whom they, the same
Jewish people had put to death 50 days
earlier and bringing forth repentance
from the people and a conversion of
thousands and baptisms that day. So, we
see these works and acts of remembrance
of God's mighty deeds, the mightiest
being the resurrection on the first day,
multiple times in the New Testament. But
on top of that, we're commanded to set
aside on the first day in remembrance of
the needs of other saints. This is
surely recalling, remember when you were
in Egypt and you yourself were um you
know in this destitute position. um the
time when the people of of the church
are supposed to set aside and to
remember brothers and sisters in need
themselves oppressed by a a mighty Roman
Empire is the first day of the week and
that's obviously a religious act
commanded on the first day. I'm aware of
all the convoluted explanations that
Seventh Day Adventists attempt to supply
that maybe Paul is just telling people
to set money aside in their own homes in
the first day really doesn't make sense
because Paul says I don't want to take a
collection when I come to you. So
clearly we have a public setting aside
taking place so that when he arrives
it's not his motus operandandy on the
surface that this guy's just showed up
to get money and he's asking for it.
it's already set aside as a collective.
So there, you know, we have the command
for a religious act of worship on that
day. And of course, we have the Lord's
day reference um as a time when John was
in the spirit. And Jesus says there's
going to come a time when people will
worship me in spirit and in truth. It's
implicit that the Lord's day is a
worship day, a day when men are are in
the spirit in worship.
So your answer is there is scriptural
support for this. It's just not the
biblicist support of a specific verse
that verbatim because they'll ask you.
They'll say show me one verse in the
Bible that says worship on Sunday. They
kind of turn into Muslims and use like
the show me where the Bible says God
Jesus is God. It has to say it verbatim
for it to be there. Um you're saying
that there's some more connecting of the
dots that's actually taking place there.
We have to we're called you know the
Bible doesn't command us to proof texts.
It actually commands us to meditate on
the word of God in numerous places from
the first psalm and onward. And I would
just note you don't to the Jehovah's W
Jo sorry 7day Adventist. I would note
that you don't have such um sorts of
direct statements about numerous things
that you you don't observe. You don't
just observe the shaat's laws condemning
con combinations of multiple sources,
multiple types of material in your
garments from Leviticus 19:19.
Uh where does the New Testament directly
say that that we have been set free from
that command? Um you know, you have to
engage in the work of theology and
understand what commands are meant for
in the first place to understand why we
wouldn't keep it. Um in explanation of
that specific verse, you know, we would
know that command existed to
differentiate the clothing of the priest
is high priestly garments having both
material from or um from plant uh
materials uh in linen garments plus from
uh animal hair. And those that
combination was a holy combination not
to be um replicated outside the temple
or tabernacle. But when you don't have a
temple or tabernacle anymore, um it's
natural to understand that those
combinations
um and and the function of those elicit
combinations no longer exists. We don't
need to make that distinction anymore.
Same thing can be gathered about all
sorts of food laws as well. We only have
one food law in the new covenant and
that is to um uh receive the the Lord's
supper in a worthy manner. Um besides
that um all food is is clean and you
know of course Jesus teaching in Mark's
uh Mark 7 and uh you know via his spirit
in Romans 14 are quite clear to that
effect but those are all theological
inferences. That's us learning to divide
the word of truth wisely and carefully.
Um, it's not the simplistic sort of
thing where for every conclusion we
draw, we point to a single verse and
pray. I'm I'm happy that that Jo, excuse
me, 7th Day Adventists are um
trinitarian. Um, but very clearly we
don't have that doctrine laid out in the
simple format that's being demanded with
respect to first day worship.
Yeah. Um, we don't want to sidetrack.
Um, maybe we can talk some other time.
I'd argue that they're not trinitarian.
They're trinitarian in name, but what
they mean by those words, um, yeah, is
probably a probably a side discussion,
but I was speaking in a judgment of
charity, my friend, because I I
understand it's just that like when I
went to seminary at Fuller, there was a
7th Day Adventist guy. He was insistent
upon being an Orthodox Trinitarian. And
I at least, you know, from individual to
individual, I like to extend that
judgment, but you're right. There's a
huge problem with uh the the the broad
sort of Adventist perspective on um on
on the Can can I ask you something
because you used to be you used to be a
seventh day Adventist, right? Okay. This
boggles my mind and I haven't had an
opportunity to ask this question to a
seventh day Advent Baptist, but
typically reformed churches that are
just getting started, uh, church plants,
they will rent the SDA on Sunday. And,
um, you know, I I know one church that
was doing that and I was visiting with
my family on vacation. And so we go into
the church and there is this there's
this
massive mural of second commandment
violation of Jesus. And you know I I
mean it's it's not even like a subtle
small one. Uh oh I know it's just huge
like I mean almost lifesize I think. Um,
and and I remember just thinking, hold
on. Like, how how does how do you get
from A to B here? That
the violation of the fourth commandment
is the mark of the beast, but violation
of the second commandment. No biggie.
Like I just it boggles my mind. And I'm
just curious, maybe you could shed some
light on that for me. Well, a couple
things. So, I have a video on this folks
on my channel during one of my Q&A. It's
a very short clip about why Adventist
churches rent out their churches to the
apostate Protestants. Um, and there's
probably some degree to them trying to
make a quick buck, but I also know some
that do it because they see it as an
evangelistic avenue to send people on
Sunday to start trying to proitize them
to come on Saturday so that they don't
get the mark of the beast. Um, so that's
one thing. The second thing on the
second commandment violations, um, the
last time I was in an Adventist church,
I could hardly even walk around with my
eyes open. I almost needed a guide to
lead me through. Um because he was pl
well these fake images were plastered
everywhere in the foyer, in the the
church, the stained glass. Um and in
their minds, man, is typically a very
simplistic view of the ten commandments.
It not only is just the letter of the
ten commandments, they don't understand
the spirit behind the law, but the
letter of the ten commandments, the
second commandment, they're going to
say, "I didn't bow down to a statue."
Yeah, that's that's kind of as far as it
goes. It's like, "We didn't bow down to
a statue." Even if we made an a
depiction of one of the members at the
godhead in this book for kids and it's
hanging in the sanctuary and it's out in
the foyer and it's on all these
materials we're sending out and our
artists are constantly depicting it.
That's not a second commandment
violation because well we're not using
it in worship even though the church
that I was in. It was a big like
plastered behind the stage where all the
worship is taking place. So right, see
this is where again I think you know
benefiting from you know just
generations of deep reflection through
that medieval period where frankly um
you know obviously that the seventh day
Adventist maybe thinks nothing good was
going on is is just so valuable because
here's the thing um you know
I I can understand the the reformed
person who makes the argument that I'm
not bowing down to an image. I I'm not
persuaded by it. Um I can understand why
they go there, but there was a really
hard push in the medieval period as kind
of like the midway between the imagists
and non-immigists that would say, well,
listen, don't put these things in
church. The entire function of what
we're doing there is to to bow down,
bend the knee metaphorically, if not
literally in worship of our God. And
when you put these things in that
particular context,
you're at least in a very dangerous
dangerous place. Even if you're not
persuaded that you've made a
representation of a member of the
godhead, which is like the hard
argument, which we could pursue further,
you know, you could make if if you're
not persuaded by that, even just the
unwisdom
of how many people there are going to
have the sense that Jesus has been
brought near by that picture or I feel
closer to Jesus when I'm by that statue.
especially when it's a house of worship
that you know the person who has a Jesus
story Bible where it's cartoonish or you
name it and it's a home
even heard some very very you know
disturbing stories there about you know
kids who felt the need to uh kiss the
picture because Jesus was there but in
an intuitive human thing that would be
to do how much more intuitive would that
be when in the house of worship
you have this thing taking attention off
of the elements of the Lord's supper the
only authorized uh sign and symbol of of
the Lord's presence in that place
besides the other worshippers who are
the body of Christ. Um you know just how
how distracting this is to everything
else. Um and then yet to carry on in the
assur self assuredness that because
we're here on the right day of the week
we don't have the mark of the beast. I
mean, the very frightening thing as the
beast is described in Revelation is
setting up an image. Um, you know, and
and so it is just it is ironic to the
core in in obviously a terrible way and
it's not something that um I I want to
make light of, but it just it's the sort
of thing that boggles the mind. And I
think the core of what you're getting at
that people may be kind of wondering
about around, you know, second
commandment violations and kind of this
broader topic is that the first and
second commandment deal with worshiping
a false god and the second commandment
is really getting at worshiping the true
God in a false way. And so images are a
way of worshiping the true God in a
false way. Um, as well as um a number of
other things you could get into
regarding um taking away from the glory
of God. um and a whole host of other
things like you said, distractions um
causing us to make an image then in our
mind as well. Um I I I've been working
for quite some time to try and like not
have an image that comes to mind when I
think of God. Um because I don't want
the stereotypical Jesus figure that's
been depicted um so frequently. Um and
that's precisely why. I want to look at
one final quote here and then we're
going to get to uh some questions if
that's fine. Just because again I want
to hear your thoughts on this. This is a
big one for them. This is from Great
Controversy page 234.
She says, quote, "The seal of God's law
is found in the fourth commandment. This
only of all the 10 brings to view both
the name and the title of the lawgiver.
It declares him to be the creator of the
heavens and the earth, and thus shows
his claim to reverence and worship above
all others. Aside from this precept,
there is nothing in the decalogue to
show by whose authority the law is
given. When the Sabbath was changed by
the papal power, the seal was taken from
the law. The disciples of Jesus are
called upon to restore it by exalting
the Sabbath of the fourth commandment to
its rightful position as the creator's
memorial and the sign of his authority.
Is the Sabbath the seal of God? Does is
that what the scriptures teach the seal
of God is? Um, okay. First off, no. I
I'm I'm gonna go into that point by just
observing a few things though. First,
what a misguided focus in one's
esquetology to be anticipating the great
day when the the real Sabbath command
gets resurrected from the dead or the
real day of the week or or something
like that. Um as opposed to,
you know, the good news of the gospel of
justification by grace alone through
faith alone. Um you know, being preached
to all nations, people being um redeemed
by saving faith in Jesus Christ. There's
just look man, I I am really persuaded
of things like everything from uh
Presbyterian polity to uh you know,
obviously our our our view of this
everything from uh the second
commandment to the fourth commandment,
you name it. But I'm just I'm not nearly
as excited about those things as um the
gospel being proclaimed, this thing that
cleanses a conscience. And I virtually
hear someone talking about the joy of
having their conscience cleansed by, you
know, worshiping on the right day of the
week. And that's just just not biblical.
Um of course in the New Testament, we
are what we have impressed upon us in
Ephesians chapter 1 13-14 um is the seal
of the Holy Spirit. um he is the one who
um first of all enlightens our minds to
the work of Christ and its significance
and its sufficiency as this thing that
gives us peace and gives us comfort and
um you know of course in Hebrews chapter
10 right before we're told not to
forsake gathering together evidently on
a different day than the Hebrew day of
worship um talks about the fact that um
we've had our conscience sprinkled clean
Um the seal by which our our conscience
is is sprinkled clean is God the Holy
Spirit in his sovereign work of
regenerating us by the blood of Jesus
Christ. And you know of course uh the
apostle John has much to say about this
uh anointing with the Holy Spirit in 1
John 2:20 and 2:27 that he teaches us
all things. Yes. By the word and
pointing us to the word. uh and the
focal point of that is he teaches us
that our redemption is finished. And um
so so that's the the high sense in which
you know Christians had a seal upon
them. God the third person of the
trinity um is that ultimate seal that we
have. Um but but I know of course God
obviously gives us sacrament sacraments
and signs. Um,
interestingly, circumcision is actually
called, you know, the sign and seal of
of um of uh justification by faith in in
Romans 4. And so, it just it's it's
curious to read these sorts of things
from Ellen White when um you know, I
feel like the more powerful case that
might be made uh would be the Judaizer
who wants to really set settle down on
circumcision. Um uh but these of course
are outward signs and seals and they
don't compete with um they're meant to
to complement um the great spiritual
reality of of regeneration and
redemption in Jesus Christ.
Amen. Bro, I love hearing that. It's
just like the gospel. The gospel. That's
what it's about. It's the gospel. And
this is where again I think there's a
huge delineation between what we're
saying and what the Seventh Day
Adventists are saying regarding the day.
It's about the substance of the day,
which is the gospel. We're there because
the gospel the day is you you pointed
out and folks, we're going to get to
your questions right after this. I just
have one comment here. Um you you
mentioned the first fruits earlier. I've
been meditating on this a lot recently,
the depth of this specific concept and
how it also typifies that we in Christ
give our first fruits of our week to the
Lord in Christ. That's right. The first
fruits of our week, the cream of the
crop, the premium, the best of the best.
Just like Jesus was the first fruits on
the first day that rose as the the um
first fruits of the of the resurrection.
Um we also give the Lord our first
fruits of our week. Um and I don't know
about Trinitos, but um at parish, you
know, the whole day is just really built
around um the worship of God's people,
the taking of the sacraments, prayer,
small group. Uh it it just fellowship.
It's not like it was in Adventism where
it's like this is permitted, that's not
permitted, this is permitted. It's like
this very rigid sort of like it's not
just worship. It's like this and this
and this. And what I found in the
reformed world, man, is people are just
not thinking that way. They're thinking
today is the day that I can bask in the
gospel. Ah, I can be reminded of the
promises of God in the covenant. we can
have uh the renewal of our covenant vows
essentially, if you will, a time of
covenant renewal to come to the Lord's
table and receive him to hear the
proclamation of his word to fellowship
with other believers in the goodness of
the gospel. It's all about the gospel.
So, and I'm and I'm just going to say
this is where this is where worship day
is significant. It's it's never to take
the place of the gospel, but this is
where worship your worship day really
does have something to say about what
you believe about the gospel. You know,
of course, in the Old Testament, you
have this this day of rest following
your work week. And you know, that was
appropriate to a people looking forward
to a Messiah to come, a Messiah to be
birthed by them in some miraculous way,
um, but who was not yet with them in the
flesh. When you think about first day
worship, we are going out from
redemption accomplished. We're going out
from a, you know, we've we have gone to
a different place in what theologians
call the historius.
Um, you know, the ordo salutus are the
events that happen in an individual
Christian's life to go from, you know,
unbelief and and and uh death to to
salvation and sanctification. Historia
salutus are the events that happen in
calendar time as God is advancing his um
redemptive plan prior to Christ. There's
this looking forward to a Messiah to
come. But there is something awesome for
believers that we go out from knowing
this man, his person, his work, this God
man, his historical life of pure active
obedience, pure passive obedience. um a
passive obedience unto the point of
death uh with the Sabbath of his his
body in the grave. And um we go out from
the first day every week to remember we
are already citizens of eternity. We are
eternal life has begun for us. Um and
this is where the day you know uh you
know is it that that uh the Sabbaths are
fulfilled in Christ the person in work
or in the Lord's day? It's kind of a
false alternative. Christ is the focal
point of a new day that is never ending
for a historical man. That's the the
point of Hebrews 4 that he has entered
into his his rest and he's in one big
blessed eternal rest day right now. And
it's because we kind of have our feet in
two worlds in time and eternity or in
scripture puts it you know where you
know sojourers passing through. We've
got, you know, uh, one foot in, um, you
could say the present evil age and in
the age to come that, yeah, you know, as
fleshly people, we still need, uh,
abdominal uh, um, remembrance, rest, but
it it is this remarkable thing that
we're going out from what is already
accomplished and what is already a
reality. And it speaks to the
completeness and wholeness of our
justification as we pursue
sanctification uh, willingly and gladly.
Amen, man. And it all just circles back
around there. It's a good way to kind of
tie it back in. It really just all
circles back around to the new creation.
Um that the new creation has begun. So
we got our first question here from
actually actual which says regarding 8th
day typology, can the Hanukkah miracle
of the manora staying lit for eight days
with only one day's worth of oil in the
newly cleansed temple be linked to the
eighth day typology of Christ?
Okay, so this is a really good question
because a lot of Christians will maybe
uh participate in like a Passover seder
uh put on by Messianic Christians and
they'll talk about kind of all the
rituals and how these things anticipate
Christ. And I want to talk I want to
mention my reservations about that sort
of a thing because it's related to this
question. you know, what is the status
of the what I would call Hanukkah myth
and uh you know, relative Christ. And I
want to um express my reservations and
then express kind of the the hint or the
tiny way in which this sort of thinking
is legitimate. Um my reservations are
that all things Hanukkah are not um to
be found in the divinely inspired word
of God. I would in fact argue that it is
so apparent that the Mcabes are not the
inspired word of God. Not only because
these books tell you that they were
written at a time when there were no
prophets alive and inspired scripture
must be prophetic literature. Um but
also the entire tone and tenor of these
books is problematic. You will search in
vain in the Old Testament for a time
when God endorses uh guerilla warfare on
the part of his people to take out
political uh sovereigns. Uh David didn't
do that. He he actually refrained from
ever killing uh um Saul. Um the heroes
of the Bible don't do that because they
they they recognized authorized
authorities even when they have to
civily disobey them. You might say the
Mcabes glorifies that sort of a thing.
It is clearly out of step with the rest
of scripture. So if I'm talking to a
Roman Catholic, I'm going to point that
out. It's one of the reasons the Jews
themselves
didn't accept those books as scripture
and and and nor frankly did the majority
of church of the church throughout
church history. And so I just look at
most of the things I'm going to read in
there about these different miracles um
with a great deal of suspicion. Now
here, let me say this though. Um
believing as I do that the whole Manura
thing probably is a myth. It's a myth
that draws heavily on genuine biblical
typology, numbers and things like that.
So I wouldn't be surprised to see this
extra biblical myth that kind of weaves
in some biblical themes would have some
aspects to it that look forward to to
Christ and especially with this sort of
eighth day typology. So I would say
somewhat inadvertently
it kind of testifies to this eighth day
theme even if it's not legitimate and
authorized by God. And therefore it
would be a it'd be natural to see that
of course these same eighth day themes
as they do in scripture anticipate an
eighth day resurrection. Yes, even the
sort of mythology surrounding the manora
would indirectly accomplish the same.
But I probably wouldn't talk about the
minora to anybody to make that point. I
would just focus on the biblical
scriptures that that convey that theme.
Excellent. We got another question here
from Ken Brooks says, "Where did God say
that the sanctifi sanctity of the
seventh day was transferred to Sunday
because Christ rose on the first day if
the seventh day is still sanctified? Why
do Christians deliberately trample it?"
Okay, so God sanctifies all sorts of
things in the old covenant. He
sanctifies all of the furniture in the
tabernacle. Are those things still
sanctified? Is there some, you know,
platonic form in which the table of
showbread still exists such that it's
sanctified? And uh, you know, why are
you neglecting that? Um, why isn't the
first order of business to get a new one
of those? Um, sanctification is
something is to set something apart for
a holy use. And we do have a sanctified
seventh day. And notably, the seventh
day that was sanctified is sometimes uh
spans a 48 hour period as opposed to a
24-hour period. Namely, when the seventh
day Sabbath happens to line up or be
followed by um immediately in
succession, one of the other Sabbaths
listed in um Leviticus 23 such that
they're sanctified. So what we would
have, you know, as first day sabotarians
is what we'd have is a 48 hour period um
in which we have a sanctified period of
rest following a succession of six days.
The seventh day Sabbath which was put in
the grave with Jesus's body and the
first day Sabbath which uh followed
immediately upon it. And it wouldn't be
any different than what we have often in
the Old Covenant where we have such a
succession. But what we do have though
is the indication in the New Testament.
the Old Testament Sabbaths, uh, weekly,
monthly, and annual. Um, they're shadows
that are no longer binding on us. Um,
that's because the antitype for all of
those types has come. That's Jesus
Christ. He's the one to whom they all
looked forward. And, uh, that all of
them, including the seventh day,
anticipated because you'll recall the
seventh day is when God rested from his
work. But it anticipated itself a day in
which man would rest from his. And it
couldn't be the seventh day itself
because man would be working to keep
God's law on that day um a as a
culmination to his works as Jesus did by
the way. Um so those are the
indications. The New Testament
indications that we are not bound to the
Old Testament Sabbaths would be the
first thing to tell you that that is not
the sanctified day any longer. And Jesus
momentous most important work in human
history is what sanctifies the first
day.
Amen.
Another question here.
Intoxicated by grace asks, "I believe
you said earlier that you believe the
Sabbath was meant for all or to all, not
just Israel. Can you expand on that?"
Oh, yeah. Great question. So, the
Sabbath is a creation ordinance. It's
something that we find in um Genesis 2.
Um you clearly have Noah working on um a
sort of uh abdominal um sort of cycle
you know things being you know after
seven days 14 days you know in the whole
um you know flood account. So you have
this indication that people are are
keeping Sabbath um or observing rest on
the seventh day before the formal
announcement of such a concept in uh the
decalogue. um you know the fact that
immediately after the people of Israel
um come to the other side of the Red Sea
um they're to gather the food um the
mana from heaven and yet they're not
supposed to gather on the the seventh
day. That's happening before we have
this formal um you know listing of this
fourth commandment in the decalogue
later in chapters 19 and 20 and at Mount
Si in this succession of the narrative.
So um yes a mankind both as a moral
commandment needs to have rest on a
regular basis and in fact um we would
argue that even a 7-day basis is um is
the natural time frame within which man
ought to do that. Um it's noteworthy
that we have had historical experiments
like Robert's Piers uh experiment in uh
the French Revolution um trying to make
everything fit with the metric system
instituting a 10-day week and everybody
was exhausted by the end of the week. Um
not everything fits on the metric
system. It was clear. So we would say
yes, there's a moral aspect of this
command that is relevant to mankind in
all ages of human history. Now it's very
clear that mankind
um very swiftly uh begins to stray from
these uh sorts of creation ordinances.
We see that before the flood. We see
that Tower of Babel. And so as a a
commemoration of redemption from Egypt,
that aspect of the Sabbath command is
unique to Israel. And many of the
ceremonial features surrounding it, such
as, you know, the the not gathering uh
or not stoking your hearthfire, for
example, um on the day would have been
unique to Israel, wouldn't have been a
natural aspect of the command to others.
I I'd go into greater depth about why
that particular feature is there. I
don't think it uh is because you're not
supposed to cook on on the day. Um but
but that would take something of an
excursion. So to summarize, from the
very beginning, man was supposed to
anticipate eternal rest from their
labors alongside of God by by taking a
rest the seventh day. mankind swiftly
strayed from that and therefore that
command is reinstituted for the people
of Israel in the decalogue. It is given
more specific uh sets of things that the
Israelites were to remember and and more
specific ceremonial aspects which
obviously other people's wouldn't keep.
And so there's a sense in which this is
for all there there are details of it
that are catered just to the people of
Israel.
Good stuff.
Next question here is from Stefan.
Stefan asks to Sunday keepers. Fine.
Ignore the seventh day in favor of the
first. Do you keep the first day holy
like the reformers taught you have to or
were they also wrong and legalistic?
Yeah. Yeah. Of course we keep it holy
because that's when we engage in the
ordinance of wor ordinances of worship
that uh are uh regularly to to be
dispensed. you regular means of grace.
Um, you know, so so for something to be
holy is to set it aside for a special
use that we do. Um, just like the
earliest Christians ever uh listened to
G uh to Peter preach a sermon on um on
uh on a Sunday and and converted in mass
and were baptized on that day and began,
you know, breaking bread together that
day. Those are the things that we do
that day. Um and it it's set apart. I
don't know why you would call that
legalistic, however. Um, I think you'd
be using that word in a different way
than the reformers use it. Um, and you'd
be using it uh in a way that kind of
convolutes the discussion. Obeying God
is not ever legalistic. If you're doing
obeying God with a view to obtaining
justification by it, that would be
legalistic. If you are adding to the
word of God um that which can't be
gathered from it by good and necessary
inference um setting up rules to keep
you far from breaking other rules, that
would be legalistic. Um but doing what
God's asked you to do is is never
legalistic. Um and we would just simply
point out, you know, obviously in
worshiping on the Lord's day, we're not
adding to God's law. We're also not
taking away from it at our convenience.
We're engaging in an act of theology
that that God has required of us when he
calls us to meditate on his word. Um and
deciphering um from a variety of texts,
you know, in a rather straightforward
way that um the day of worship has been
altered by the Lord of the Sabbath
himself.
Yeah. I think the thing that he's
getting at is that oftentimes SDAs get
called legalistic, but they're missing
the point here. The legalistic claim is
not coming, Stefan, because you guys
merely claim to be sabotarians. The
legalistic claim comes in when you guys
say it's the seal of God. Those who in
the end are not adhering to your guys's
tradition are going to be lost. That's
where it's legalistic. It's not simply
the idea that you guys still think if
you want to worship on Saturday, I mean,
go for it. You're, you know, you're free
to worship on Saturday. No one's coming
for you. We don't want to hunt you guys
down like the big claim is. But the
legalistic aspect comes in when you
attach the problematic aspect, which is
that it's the seal of God. Miles, that's
well said. Um, and I would only add one
part. Um, I would probably be less
likely to say go ahead and worship on
Saturday. I would say, you know, the
Lord has called you to worship on
Sunday, but he hasn't called you to do
so to obtain justification thereby or to
evade, you know, having had the mark of
the beast. He did so for a variety of
reasons. One of which is to, you know,
have fellowship with all the all your
other believers in, you know, in Christ
who have justification by faith alone.
Um, and uh, in that respect, there's
just there's so much benefit to it for
you and and for other people. And of
course, obviously, always obeying the
Lord is a good thing. Um, but I can say,
listen, if you're not persuaded of those
things, I'm not as worried as I am if
you're not persuaded of justification by
grace alone through faith alone. And
that's that's that's what both Miles and
I are saying. The minute you put the day
you worship as uh something additional
to rest receiving and rest resting upon
Christ alone for salvation um something
you must do to obtain that grand end
then we have a real big problem and and
we're going to call SDA theology
legalistic.
This is more of a statement but I think
it's kind of a question as well or
something you could expound upon because
you did earlier. Chris Lucas says, "The
main thing I disagree with this guy
about is Matthew 12:40. It says three
days and three nights. That means
there's got to be three periods of
daylight and three periods of night. If
the verse said three days and nights,
that's a whole different story and he
can make the argument he's making, but
it says three days and three nights."
What are your thoughts on that? Well,
the thing I disagree with this guy about
is that that's even possible. The Bible
says that Jesus was going to have his
body destru destroyed and in three days
raise it up. You can't have three full
days and three nights in a grave and
also rise from the dead on that third
day from which the death and burial took
place. It's mathematically impossible.
You're asking for more, Lucas, than some
sort of consistent reading of the Bible.
You're asking for numbers and math to be
altered itself. It's not possible. It's
very simple. If a man is killed on a
Monday and he's going to rise on the
third day after that, that'd be
Wednesday, there's no way to get that
body in the grave for 72 hours in
between. And there are literally scores
of references in the New Testament to
the fact that Jesus was raised on the
third day. That's why you have to engage
in the business of being a serious Bible
interpreter and looking at how numbers
are used. You will find it again and
again and again. Pick up your
concordance, friend. Pick it up. Look at
the number three in the Bible and how
many times you will read that something
spanned three days and yet the end of it
happened on the third day. That's
because there are two phenomena that you
will find all throughout the scriptures.
counting things inclusively of the parts
and exclusively of the parts. Look at
the trans transfiguration, my friend.
It's not hard. Look at at Mark chapter 9
and look at Luke chapter 9. You tell me
how many days elapsed between Peter's
confession of Christ and the
transfiguration. One says six, one says
eight. There are different ways about
speaking about a time frame, different
ways of counting them, and they're both
perfectly legitimate. But your
interpretation of the passage, friend,
is strictly impossible.
All right,
Ken Brooks asked another question. What
are your thoughts on Isaiah 66:22
through 23?
Yeah. So, uh, one of the things that
we're going to say, I mean, obviously
that's, you know, from Sabbath to
Sabbath, from new moon to new to new
moon, uh, talking about worship. Um,
there, of course, we're talking about a
passage that's esqueologgical import.
Um, can either be taken as referring to,
um, or plausibly be taken as referring
to an eternal rest or perhaps to to a a
millennial form of worship. And that's
going to draw in how you view the
millennium and how you view eternity.
Notably, um, new moon to new moon is the
first day, uh, is the first day of a
month. So, we like that aspect of it and
we think its typological significance is
pointing us to a first day of worship.
But what we'd also say is that that
passage cannot be understood as if what
we are to look forward to is a simple
reinstitution of Jewish forms of worship
in eternity. This because Colossians is
too clear in telling us that um the uh
Old Testament Sabbaths uh first day,
monthly, excuse me, weekly, monthly, and
annual are mere shadows and not things
by which Christians are bound. So what
we see is a prophecy of new covenant
worship in which the first day of of the
new moon and the heabital day the the
one day and seven are combined in the
first day of the week which combines
them. And then what we have is first day
worship going forth. And one compelling
proof for that might be pointing out
that earlier in that same passage, we're
told that from the gentile nations, you
will have priests for God. How do you
have that with a strict keeping of the
letter of the commandment where a
priesthood is given the Aeronic
priesthood given to the sons of Aaron
but not given to foreigners. What we
have to contemplate therefore is the
fulfillment of prophecy in a more
wonderful way than a simple
straightforward application of what the
text says as most prophecies contain
such sorts of elements. Uh you know the
virgin birth prophecy um could be read
in a couple of different ways and would
not have necessarily brought to mind the
miracle that it actually foretells. We
would just simply point out that a
miracle takes place here. God's people
is going to be marked by Jews and
Gentiles together. And as a result, uh
to the degree that she has clergy, uh
those preachers, those ministers will
not simply come from the stock of Aaron
anymore. They will be combined in one.
And in the same fashion, when we look
forward to this worship that is
rhythmic, um, and we take that as a
reference to the millennial sort of
worship that we have in the church,
we're anticipating one in which new
moons and Sabbaths are consolidated into
one day and that is kept rhythmically
and that bowing down takes place and
that's what we think we have in the
first day of the week. And um I should
note as well that um this is the sort of
truncation of all things that came
before that we have all throughout the
New Testament. We have one faith and one
baptism. That's an incredible thing
because in the Old Testament we had
scores of baptisms for uh any sort of
cleansing that needed to take place by
contact with the dead or a menstrual
cycle or different things. There would
be cleansings to undergo. All of those
cleansings have come together in one
baptism in the New Testament, including
circumcision itself, which was another
type of cleansing. And we would know the
same thing is happening with holy days.
The same thing is happening with food.
There were numerous food laws in the Old
Testament by which we are no longer
bound because we have one meal, one uh
feeding upon Christ himself. And um
therefore, all of those things are
fulfilled in that. So we find the
fulfillment in this. It shall be from
new moon to new moon and from Sabbath to
Sabbath all mankind will come to bow
down before me says the Lord. We find
that fulfilled in the new day when Jesus
was raised from the dead. And for 2,000
years people have been coming and doing
just that, bowing down and worshiping
the Lord on that day.
Amen. Adventists love to point to this
to try and just deduce out of it. Well,
it says that we're going to be keeping
the seventh day Sabbath in heaven.
That's just evidence that it's going to
be kept in heaven. There's just when you
do such a, and I don't mean to be
insulting in this, but just in
technicalities, when you do such a
remedial reading of the text and don't
think about things like, well,
Revelation 21 says there is no sun and
moon. So, how are there going to be
literal new moons? You know, if you're
going to take the Sabbath literally like
that, and you're missing the
esqueological implications of of kind of
what's actually being said there. Miles,
I'm going to say one more thing. You're
absolutely right about that. And you
know, if if someone hears this, and I
imagine an Adventist would maybe with
something of an inclination for
something like literal fulfillment. You
know, I would not know the same passage.
It just verses before it says, "Then
they shall bring all your brethren in
from uh from all the nations as a grain
offering to the Lord." Here we already
even have this sort of symbolic sense
that grain offerings themselves are
going to be replaced with people. Uh the
the New Testament fulfillment of this is
going to be wonderful in what was
symbolic in the old a shadow in the old
like the multiplicity of holy days are
going to be truncated and fulfilled in
the one man Jesus Christ in his eternal
day. Um, that's what we had anticipated
if we're even paying attention to these
sorts of details in the text. From the
fact that people can be called a grain
offering, from the fact that we can
speak of Gentiles functioning as u
ministers, formal ministers of the
people um all of these things point us
to the concept that um we're looking at
a more wonderful fulfillment than what
we've seen in the past in human history.
That's good.
Got another one here. Question from
Jamie Russell. Did Jesus mean Saturday
or Sunday when he said, "Pray your
flight not come on the Sabbath day in
Matthew 24." This is postc cross uh
postc cross future event. Uh I'll say
one thing and then I'll pass it to you.
Um and that would just be your
esqueological school, brother. That's
going to influence your understanding of
of why Jesus is saying what he's saying
here. Um, Adventists love to point to
this to say, "See, this is talking about
the end of the world, showing that the
seventh day Sabbath was still going to
be observed at the very end of time."
Um, and Jesus is talking about um, I
would argue, and we'll see what you say,
I would argue Jesus is not talking about
the very, very, very end of the world.
He's talking about a very specific event
that's about to take place. Yeah. You
know, truth is, you'll find reformed
people who say both things as well.
You'll find reformed people who point to
this that there is a you know because
obviously we we've already talked a lot
about Hebrews 4, we do have a Sabbath
days rest that um is is going to uh be
perpetuated until the last day. And so
let me just put it this way. If you took
the the um more historicist
postmillennial reading as opposed to
predtoist millennial reading, that's the
way you would go. you would say this is
an indication that God's people will
have a day of rest that um you know they
wouldn't want to find themselves caught
off guard in you know this cumbersome
position of tribulation um maybe all
throughout human Christian church
history maybe especially you know at a
point near the end of the millennium
things like that um but of course as you
said there's a predtoous reading of the
passage as well that this warning uh
being spoken by Jesus uh has great
reference to the events of AD.70 where
um you Perhaps you have uh Christians
like you know we it seem to be implied
in a variety of passages in the New
Testament that are keeping both the
seventh day and the first day. You call
them maximalists. Um I have a lot to say
about that sort of practice in my um the
article that I should be published later
this year. Um because there were people
who did that. There were people who
tried to be circumcised and baptized.
You know there were people who tried to
do it all. You could say and of course
this that would be very hard practice.
Um, and it would be a perfectly natural
warning to, you know, anticipate that
sort of thing is going to happen in the
transitional period of the early church
in the first 40 years of it. Um, and
look out. Um but uh I I guess I would if
you want me to like hunker down in one
here, I would lean toward the view that
he's he's warning Christians that um you
know even first day observance um this
the Sabbath as it's going to be Christ's
Sabbath, his Lord's day, uh it would be
a cumbersome time to find oneself uh you
know in the city of Jerusalem surrounded
by armies um even in AD.70. Um, and not
to mention all the plightes the church
might suffer throughout history when the
church is not watchful.
Good stuff. This will probably be our
last question here, folks. Again, from
Stefan says, "If there's no sun or moon
on the new earth, how will we know when
to go worship?" I'll say one thing on
this, then I'll let you chime in. Um,
Stephano, as as it pertains to the sun
and the moon, I would just tell you to
go to God's word on that. That's what
God's word says. Revelation 21:23, the
city does not need the sun or the moon
to shine on it for the glory of God
gives its light and the lamb is its
lamp. So, I'm just reiterating there
what the scriptures say and that it's
not a strong connection to try and say
Isaiah 66 says the seventh day Sabbath
like we understand it is going to be
observed in eternity where there is a
7-day week with rotations around the
sun. And again, this kind of gets into
that what I was saying earlier about
having this sort of divine
characteristic to the seventh
24-hour rotation around the sun. Curious
to hear your thoughts on that, Dr.
Bosserman. Well, oh, yeah. So the the
question presupposes that this is
necessarily a um prophecy either
primarily or strictly about eternal
eternity in the eternal state um as
opposed to either primarily or partially
about um the state of the church in the
millennium or uh in the kingdom period
prior to eternity. Um in eternity
it it would be the position of the
reformed that there isn't going to be
anything like abdominal worship. There's
going to be perpetual worship all the
time without cessation. That's the
picture that we have of worship in the
heavenlies. It's not just that they're
saying holy, holy, holy for a a seventh
day Sabbath or a new moon festival. That
is their chant at all times. So when we
talk about Jesus entering into his rest,
he is in his eternal exaltation with the
father. And what we anticipate in
eternity is eternal celebration in
Christ of the God who sent his son uh to
redeem us uh in God the Holy Spirit. And
we look at every first day worship
service as a taste of the eternity to
come. So of course we talked about how
worship days um you know anticipate an
esquetology and they look back to
something that's that's been uh com been
done by God in human history. So, in so
far as Isaiah 66 points us to eternal
worship, we'd say these are the sorts of
signs and symbols to convey that the
best you got is perpetual worship or
rhythmic worship. But what we have set
before us in Revelation 20 and 22 is
perpetual. that it's precisely the fact
that we've entered the one eternal day
as the Christian hymn on uh Jordan's
Stormy Banks I stand uh celebrates. But
in so far as prophetic passages tend to
have applications that are more
immediate than their fullest
fulfillment. Um we see an incredible um
you know sort of foretaste of
fulfillment in Christian worship right
now for the last 2,000 years. All
mankind will come to bow down before me,
says the Lord. And they don't come to
the city of Jerusalem on the map next to
the Mediterranean, as it says in
Hebrews, uh rather uh chapter 12. They
come to the heavenly city, New
Jerusalem, every Lord's day, when they
so worship. And that is kind of the the
first taste of fulfillment in this
passage.
Yes, we do look upon the corpses of men,
as it says in verse 24, who have
transgressed against me, for their worm
will not die. When we have the word of
God preached to us, the bad news of the
consequences of unbelief, yes, we see
this fate. And when we have the good
news preached of of Jesus victory, um we
bow down before the Lord every Lord's
day as, you know, a foretaste of
fulfillment of this passage.
Miles, I think you your microphone's
off. I can't hear you. So, I know you
want to say something. You're correct. I
was just saying amen. That's a good note
to end on. Um uh there's a lot that I
want to chime in on that, but we would
also be here all night and I know that
it's uh we're getting about two hours
and 20 minutes or so. So, if you want to
let people know what sort of material
can they find from you, where can they
find it, where can people listen to
anything that you may have done,
anything else you'd like to share before
we sign off? Sure. Yeah. You know, all
my sermons are in sermonaudio.com. So,
if you looked up Trinitos Presbyterian
Church or you looked up Brent Boston,
you could find it there. I think you
mentioned my book earlier on, Trinity
and the Vindication of Christian
Paradox. And then, you know, I just I
have some friends that say for example
uh gentler reformation.com
uh that they're kind enough to let me um
post, you know, various articles and
things as a guest author. So, I've
written some things, you know, an
article on critical race theory or on um
what it means to uh submit to the
governing powers in Romans 13. And if
you just searched on there, you could
find some stuff. I've also got some
things that um you know, monarchism.com,
which is a reformed uh site with all
sorts of different resources. I they've
picked up different things I've done on
there. Um you know, I did a a debate
with a unitarian that you can find on
YouTube named Shawn Finnegan. Um, but
the main thing right now is my my
ministry has to be in in preaching. You
know, as I I'm a minister, uh, church
planter of of 10 years. Um, and I've got
a family with kids, uh, you know,
spanning from 14 to eight. I've I've got
my hands tied at the moment to to to say
the least. So, I'm I'm not as productive
as I'd like to be with, you know,
written things, but again, you know,
publishing an article this fall. Um, and
Lord willing, more in the future.
Amen. Well, brother, I really appreciate
you coming on here. I think that this
was again a heavy dose of spiritual
meat. I would love to have you back
after that article comes out. I want
people to understand this is an
exogetical article, meaning it's dealing
with the scriptural text and giving
biblical support. And if you understand
the Adventist position on this, as you
saw the quotes tonight, the claim is
there is not an iota of scriptural
support for why the church meets on the
first day. We got a taste of that
tonight. Uh thank you my friend. Uh and
like I said, hopefully we will have you
back. Uh until next time, we'll uh we'll
see you next time.
And you know, maybe one last thing,
Miles, uh if there's a way to get the
link to um the article. It sounded like
there was a solid question there about
uh Jesus rising from the the dead on on
a Sunday. Um I've got a pretty involved
article on that topic that um I don't
know if you you have a place you can
post in the chat below. I can put it in
the description box. That'd be great. If
you send it to me, I'll put it in the
description box. I'm going to do it.
I'll send it to you. Perfect. All right.
Well, brother, again, thank you so much
for being here and uh we'll see you
around next time. Yep. God bless you.
Yeah, you too.
All right, folks. So, I hope that that
was beneficial for y'all. I hope that um
this maybe answered some questions. I
know that we have a wide audience of
viewership from former Adventist,
current Adventist, never been an
Adventist, um atheist, all sorts of
stuff. And so I hope that this was
challenging in a good way. Um I hope you
heard some stuff tonight that maybe you
disagree with, maybe you do agree with.
Um what we really want is for it to
cause you and provoke you to get into
the scriptures deeper and to see that
there's a much deeper thing going on
around the Sabbath than sort of this
mystical divine attachment to the
seventh day like the Adventist church
has so um polluted the minds of so many
people to think. Um, and I think that a
lot of people have maybe overcorrected
to some degree the other direction. Um,
and there's really a balance that's
found in understanding kind of the
bigger picture of what's going on. And
it's that Jesus Christ is ultimately the
substance. And we remember that, we
celebrate that the new creation. Um, our
redemption, the work of our redemption
being accomplished and completed on the
first day of the week. Um, and that's
not necessarily found by doing this sort
of where does the Bible say explicitly
these exact words, the Sabbath was
changed to Sunday. Well, it it doesn't.
And that's not an actually an actual
onetoone of what we're saying. We're
we're talking about a narrative from
start to finish that's pointing
somewhere that's going somewhere about
something much deeper. And so hopefully
tonight was beneficial for you on that
front. A couple housekeeping things. Um,
next week we have Aaron Lyles on the
show, former Adventist, now a Baptist
pastor. We're going to be talking about
the state of the dead and the nature of
man, the depravity of man, um, a week
from tonight. Um, I got a couple other
things scheduled. Um, for the Adventist
apologists that watch the show, guys,
you've been quiet since I sent you back
um, the uh, offers to come on to the
program and give us the best
presentation that you can for um, a list
of 10 different beliefs um, or 10
different claims that are specifically
distinct and unique to Adventism. None
of you guys have responded. what's going
on? You wanted to talk about the
Sabbath, so you heard a little bit of a
primer tonight. Um, that was one of the
options as well. So, get back with me so
that you guys can come on here as well.
Um, and we can have some Adventist
voices that are on here. But, as always,
I'm going to end it on the same note
that I always uh end it on. And that is
the call to Adventist, the same thing
that they call us to. Come out of her,
my people. Come to know the truth. Come
to know the true gospel. There's nothing
nefarious. There's nothing evil about
Sunday. There's nothing about Christians
following after the papacy and
Constantine. These sort of things are
conspiracies, folks. They're
conspiracies. They're not rooted in
history. You have to throw out all of
Christian history and have some sort of,
you know, this small little sliver of
people have been this small little group
that's always maintained this sort of
idea. Um, when really when you apply
AAM's razor here, um, the obvious answer
is that no, the Adventist church is just
wrong, folks. There is a biblical basis
for this. Dr. Boserman gave us a primer
on this tonight. I'm sure his article is
going to be much more thoroughly um well
it's again it's an ex exogetical
argument um an exegetical article and so
I'm sure it will go a lot deeper than we
did tonight. So again my call would be
come out of her my people come to know
the truth. We'll see you guys next time.
God bless.
[Music]